to welcome everybody uh to the H3
podcast it's May 24th what is up
everybody thank you for being here
yes yes
today we have a uh a special episode
Ethan Klein presents
where we finally address uh you know uh
Abba and preach or Babylon reach I think
is what we've settled on yeah
Crow I'm gonna eat Pro today on a few
things
one of them is the peaches and cream I'm
gonna eat crow on that big time but
where but yeah I know all right settle
down Dan
but um
we have so much to get into you know
uh these guys
Abba and preach Babylon reach they've
been talking like
a lot they've been talking about me a
lot not just me like some of the crew
members too for example what did they
call Olivia Zach
yeah
okay if you don't know who Olivia is
she's the loser feminist researcher who
spends all her Day on Reddit boards and
thinks that's research okay
right so that you know that that that I
got to stand up for my girl do you do
you think you're a loser dumb loser
feminist or do you say dumb or just
loser feminine you don't know who Olivia
is she's the loser feministers
sorry I mean what they're criticizing me
I messed up true so in that moment yeah
I was does it make you a feminist though
I mean that's a compliment to me I'm a
feminist right so thanks guys love you
love you so much yeah but I'll tell you
what this is off the rails but I'm Gonna
Keep it level-headed today you know I
mean I got my warm water here
warm water oh yeah hot water warm water
where does that come from that's what
maturity leads to it leads to you're
cutting out the beverages those the sodi
pops the coffee I'm sit I'm settling
down on a nice cup of warm water why is
it warm why not ice water cold water no
no warm because it's I already said it's
spicy it's exciting it's Dynamic I
always drink the tea I always drink cold
water for white people spicy is uh warm
water zesty
zesty but in truth my throat I'm having
throat pain oh so
I figured maybe some throat coat
love me some Throat Coat let's coach
your throat up I can't help but help
think that that sounds sexual like
obscene throat coat something wrong with
that no it's not I just go coat my
throat let you coat my throat anytime
thanks I'm sexual about it thank you bro
yeah so uh
I gotta say there's so much
of them talking about us there's 15
videos in total of them talking about me
and Hassan eight about me that I counted
and the topics that they cover
are just pretty nuts in general
here's a list of things they've
criticized before uh imitating Elon Musk
that was horrible yeah I agree with them
on that one that was over the line
you're the only person to do that too
yeah they got me on that one doxing
people for fun which I'm excited to talk
about that one we love doxing people
folks we have a long enough history
actually
falsely accusing people of essay I can't
I'm looking forward to talking about
that one uh pushing fake narratives for
money
pushing fake narratives against people I
disagree with
um ruining the sanctity of debate
actually they defended Stephen Crowder
that is the biggest offense well they
didn't defend it let's see how bad is a
sacred institution I'll say they didn't
defend Crowder but in the uh Sam Cedar
event they said they both look dumb and
Ethan destroyed the sanctity of debate
I'm paraphrasing yeah
uh let's see uh being a liberal racist
being insecure being slimy there's a
whole lot of silliness here so to
actually address everything they've said
about me I don't know that I could
possibly even do all that but I've done
my best to kind of hit on the best
things
uh that that I could put together here
and this is this is quite a long one so
uh bear with us but I hope you guys are
going to enjoy it I think that we've
done a pretty good job of proving the
thing about them Babylon reach is that
I feel that their whole
schtick is that
they they're above everything they don't
care about anything they're not attached
we make fun of everyone and we just say
it like it is
but when you look at it but when you
look at them holistically you can I I we
were I don't think they're that much
different than fresh and Fit I mean
they're not as in Sally
they're smarter but when it comes down
to it you're I'm I'm going to show you
guys blatant transphobia
okay chill out coconuts and Barbados
wait your turn he's feeling a little
upstaged right now yeah I'm sorry bro
uh although you know and coconuts and
Barbados and preach have a lot in common
too I think they just kind of
sit there
thank you Olivia feminist loser
uh you know and they have they have a
their yeah blatant misogyny blatant uh
transphobia insane hypocrisy and just
generally defending awful people and
just generally being awful
um they laugh at this claim Hassan's
been talking about them being
transphobic for a long time and they
they don't really respond to it they
just laugh if you watch a lot of the
videos you'll notice that they're not
actually interested in responding to um
valid criticism they just laugh and let
that stand for itself they're like we
laughed
I feel like that's disrespectful to the
institution of debate
oh we're going to help them highly
respect here at the History Podcast and
today we will prove in our thesis that
is them who do not respect the sanctity
of that that's right
that's right boys get those marchina
yeah so we've got a whole lot here
and uh from bad to worse in my opinion
and I do think I will give a a trigger
warning to people who are sensitive this
because I'll tell you there's
definitely transphobia a misogyny victim
blaming there's a lot of bad stuff in
here you know what I mean
and I feel like I I almost I identify
with them in the sense that I used to do
what they do so I know exactly where
they are in the sense that I used to be
this enlightened Centrist around the
time we started the podcast I used to
appeal to
this same kind of men that they're
appealing to now
and
I I can't speak for them but what it did
to me is it kind of started warping me
and changing me to cater them until I
came to the point where I realized
that I was encouraging and fostering a
community of really horrible people
I'm not saying all their fans is
horrible I don't know but I'm just
saying I know the headspace they're in
they're kind of stuck they're they can't
a lot of their criticism of me I feel
like is just straight pandering to the
um Fallen fans
and it works quite well their videos
when they use my name do do quite well
for them
and so basically with all that being
said I think what let's just get right
into it
um
you know what I mean
so here it is so well let me start this
off by just giving a shout out to uh
their last video on us I had to
acknowledge this legend in the comments
te Zonday of Chocolate Rain Fame
had the top comment edited of course
hold on a second oh we got a frozen
monitor one moment here
oh I didn't realize I was enjoying the
[__] cab mug oh wow
looking forward to meeting him soon but
I sip this in our mediation that'd be
good
I'm like yes Ryan go on maybe we could
make a to-go mug that says the same
thing just a whole line of yeah are we
good Dan or
okay cool
yeah so take my boy tasande of Chocolate
Rain Fame uh Chocolate Rain Fame is
invested
he said oh boy this is going to go on
and on popcorn emojis let's go I didn't
know you were a drama handbook I'm gonna
make a chocolate rain up in this [__]
on and on and on I love that so eat your
heart out Tay zande uh we love you just
turned 41 years young hey Sunday
wow
my God so close now let me uh no
speaking of music legend not close did
you hear him the breaking news was we
just lost oh Tina Turner just passed
away like it was announced like an hour
ago oh no so shout out to our girl Tina
you're a legend yeah I suggested we put
fortina in the beginning of the episode
yeah 14-0
Tina
uh okay recipes Tina Turner
great I mean terrible not great terrible
not great
um I here's my quick way to start this
off okay now as I was saying they've
made a ton of videos about me and Hassan
I have never properly responded to them
and they're they're just like content
vultures parasites like do you say any
dumb thing and they'll turn it into a
whole episode so I've been putting off
getting into with these guys because I
know it's just going to be a whole thing
but uh for now
it's a Babylon reach season on the H3
podcast uh it's open season now
Ethan Klein Hassan threatened to go to
war with us Ethan Klein is embarrassing
this was about
oh we have another freezing uh all right
it's cold in here dude
it's cold
it's kids freezing cold up in there
sorry you ever met Tay zande I have met
taser oh really I met him at Jack film's
birthday party that's random he was
talking to me about a friend of his
who's addicted to kratom
it's a pretty interesting combo okay you
know I didn't know that people got
addicted to Kratom but yeah I guess
there's someone out there for every
Everything hmm what is that I'm sorry
forgive my ignorance it's like
it's like a painkiller right it's some
weird herbal
Far Eastern Indian thing where it's like
gives opiate like effects and it's legal
just because I don't think it's been
regulated yet or at least last time I
checked maybe it has been now you can
just buy like pounds of it online and
it's but it's really nasty uh
green powder that you drink it's gross
it is really nasty [__]
but okay so bat so anyway yeah so this
one Ethan Klein is embarrassing was
actually about if you can believe the
Sebastian The Tick Tock alpha male they
were defending him
yes
he did Crush that debate so I understand
Ethan Ethan Clyde is mad at us because
they're insecure and hate me because I'm
fat I don't know what that is about uh
if you play Hot this is a Hassan one
this is a Hassan one
uh how is H through H3 not Perma band
for this this one I'm very excited to
talk about that's coming up later
um Ethan Klein gets devoured by the
monster he helped create I'm assuming
this was probably about I love the
picture they used yeah this is a popular
one I know I remember what exactly this
was from we raised a whole bunch of
money on charity so it's actually really
fond memory and I do love come
on there's all kinds of uh issues going
on I'm seeing in the chat everyone's
saying YouTube is crashing for them oh
great perfect timing minded too YouTube
crash my YouTube app crashed dude
is this thing on are we good to keep
going
yeah you're good YouTubers I mean people
are watching I'm just seeing a lot of
people in the chat saying they're app
crash yeah I'm seeing that this is uh a
wider issue going on
uh okay well hopefully that gets
resolved
people are clamoring for this episode
they crashed the whole damn website
so anyway uh I think this was about my
Ben Shapiro jokes and
I don't know uh this is like the Jordan
Peterson take about like oh
you're you're the the mob you created
um lots of Hassan stuff Ethan or HD goes
after fresh and fit with fake me too
claims this was about the caller we had
me too who described her bad date and
these guys this was possibly the lowest
point for them in my opinion uh I can't
wait to talk about this how they
maliciously went after this girl called
her a liar and sent a hate mob after
literally doxing her which is ironic
we'll get into that looking forward to
it update proof she's lying they show
her face and they say her name in the
video
like and he literally says I'm saying
her name because people need to know it
I was like okay dude interesting that
you care about doxing
uh and then defending Stephen Crowder so
a fair and balanced view on uh the H3 uh
that the H3 problem
um let's see here
so
also I just want to point this out at
the top this is their banner I just
thought this was funny we talk about tab
use subjects
social issues and culture ooh taboo this
is like uh
week one YouTube YouTube Banner yeah
we're gonna talk about taboo subjects
you guys like TR I like trans people are
actually lame
most people a lot of people say trans
people should exist we say they
shouldn't
taboo
6 million is a really big number don't
that is a taboo subject my friend oh
that's you don't mention that one
it's a taboo that's a taboo what I'm not
saying she deserved it but all I'm
asking is what if
um just saying just saying yeah okay so
this clip they always show
of Hassan saying transphobia I guess he
he did a response to them
and he said transphobia a whole bunch of
times in a video talking about
transphobia to me it doesn't strike me
as that interesting but they love it
here it is transphobic transphobic
transphobic transformed it's just
grieving so like he was mean to us so
we're gonna yeah man you [__] got me
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobes transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobic I
don't know why it's even funnier
watching him watch himself say
transphobic a hundred times and just see
how awkward it is
this is probably the most rewarding edit
I've ever done watching him react to
himself say transphobic a million times
is actually one of my greatest editing
moments but anyways and I want people to
have okay so that's his that's his
cherished moment they're uh I I'd
personally said the word a lot though
dude this is kind of like
spot on for their arguments they don't
explain why it's a problem
they just go he said transphobic a bunch
so therefore he's a [__] idiot like
there's no unpacking of it but okay if
saying a word a lot of times
is a symptom of something then I got bad
news for you buddy we prepared our own
little edit in your honor your guys's
honor uh about the amount of time so uh
you guys have talked about trans people
on your channel which to my account is
like 30 plus videos it's hard to even
keep track of them all but here is uh
Babylon reach saying transphobia like
160 times so I've been banned from an
event now the organizer told me was
about a video I did about trans people
and doing our catalog we've only done
two videos about trans people a few
moments later a trans person the trains
not transports all transgender stuff the
trans women trans people trans people
trans people trans women trains trans
people trans women
Transit transfers
we're not okay with trans
men trans people trans people who don't
[Music]
ain't nobody trying to talk about y'all
that deeply you guys just won't shut the
[__] up and you guys are in every news
article always and trying to cancel
folks of course ain't nobody talking
about Native Americans or indigenous
folks the same way they're talking about
you no one's talking about the Maui
people the same way they're talking
about you the reason why folks talk
about y'all is because you guys put
yourselves out there all the time and
then constantly demand and change from
everybody
[Music]
I just felt bad for cam at a certain
point it was like Clockwork Orange back
there his eyes were propped open with
two toothpicks and I think he was just
about to fall into the abyss if he had
to keep doing that but it's safe to say
there's a lot more of those that didn't
even make the cut is that right Kim yeah
oh yeah I can look at their word right
now on a waveform and uh identify which
one is trans that's awesome he's like
he's Neo you know NEOS use the world in
Code Year and M just sees the waveforms
all around him that's awesome I can only
identify trans but you know it's there
um
I asked cam last night when I was
putting this together as a kid does
anyone remember this clip here and Kim's
like I got it
I know exactly where it is he was
plugged in boy yeah so if if saying the
word a bunch of times is a symptom of
something then boy I don't know what
this says about you buddy
uh well it does say something you guys
are singularly focused and obsessed with
talking about trans people
um you know if you just look
at their Channel
which is what Hassan urged them to do uh
where's this one of them
you could you pull up that clip of
um
they cut out in their response to us
Hassan going go to their Channel and
type Trans in the search bar you can see
how many videos they've made on the
topic it's it's getting obsessive it's
getting absurd it's getting uh
parasiticism it's obviously
yeah it's obviously not a good faith
thing and they cut it out in their
response I could just show you right now
if you want to
yeah pull up their Channel we talk about
everything social issues
so you just type tracks you know but to
be fair it might be fair and balanced
you know kind of coverage
um
right like titles trans protester loses
it protester loses it Dave Chappelle
jokes are dangerous says trans idiot
wasn't your business transcompetent
uh guess who got beaten up trans women
with a criminal record enters a female
prison I don't see a lot of pro-trans
pieces here there might be one Buried
one or two buried in here though to be
fair though it might it's just it's such
a huge volume and it's hard to
it's hard to navigate all of it yeah so
I mean they love to say they laugh when
Hassan goes they're transphobic they
just laugh of course they don't say
anything that's how they argue they just
laugh and apparently their fans were
supposed to uh
just accept that it's absurd on face but
I mean let's let's be real guys you have
an issue
um so here let's kind of talk about the
transphobia thing I'm gonna highlight
what I believe is blatant transphobia
I'm going to highlight blatant misogyny
I'm going to talk about the perma-ban
hypocrisy and then we're going to get
into uh the uh reacting to their videos
specifically
so
I find it just funny on face that ABBA
was banned from an event for being
transphobic
now oops that doesn't mean he's
transphobic but I don't know anyone
who's I don't know anybody who's been
banned from an event for being
transphobic I mean
certainly it doesn't look great and from
an event now the organizer told me it
was about a video I did about trans
people and knowing our catalog we've
only done two videos about trans people
what a lot has changed my friend a lot
has changed hasn't it
only two how about yeah only two one
about sports oh yes and one about not
wanting to date a transgender person yes
yes and so this transgender people in
sports I mean most feminists agree with
what we're saying so I doubt it was that
one some they do that a lot too where
they just go most feminists agree with
this most there's lots of trans people
that they just they [__] talk out of
their ass Non-Stop
I want to just assume it was the one
where we first started getting flat
which was Bob Riley did this one yes so
but there's a lot of that really agree
with what we're saying there it is oh
yeah no no there's tons of trans people
who agree with us tons of feminists that
agree with us
tons of Nazis
we're just throwing them out there
I think Hitler actually shared that
opinion with you
if he was alive I'm sure he would
but I don't want to rely on that
argument because it's just yeah then
why'd you say it
yeah absolutely so we can't rely on that
us not wanting to date trans people it's
not something that we've been shouting
out at the top of her lungs her whole
life I've said it once in my life and
that was during that video and the only
reason I said it in that video was
because Riley was accusing anybody who
wasn't interested of being transphobic
okay so I'm setting this up but they're
they're uh basically response
is well nobody likes you anyway trans
people he says uh here that excuse why
transphobia is trans people's fault
because they're annoying I guess this is
extremely important and why I think
everybody should be listening to what
we're saying is that if you haven't
heard recently people between the ages
of 18 to 34 are actually now less
accepting of lgbtq people than they were
over a year ago and this dropped by over
eight percent so what does that mean
that you know there's always this Mantra
that young people are inherently going
to be more and more liberal and that
they're going to be more but we're
actually seeing the opposite thing being
true and so I would tell people part of
why I think this is becoming true is
that people are seeing some of the
tactics that lgbtq activists are using
in order to further their agenda so
again this is like really classic
bigotry where it's it's the trans
people's fault
why people hate them more I mean
it's not it's their responsibility to
make sure that people are more accepting
of them uh is is really really a
I don't know what to say it's
transphobic take
trans people don't need to uh
debate with you they're
validness to exist you know what I mean
not all conversations are worth having
you know
trans people don't need to justify their
existence
or Justify why people shouldn't hate
them on face
you know
like these guys do this a lot I just
want to have a conversation I just want
to talk about it they don't want you
having a conversation some conversations
are not worth having I'm sorry like as a
Jew I don't think I need to have a
conversation with the Nazi about why I
shouldn't be exterminated
both sides of that argument are not
equal
I know that's I think it's running away
from another debatey thing coward coward
come debate me why do you think you
shouldn't be gassed
coward is just avoiding a conversation
now that's an extreme example obviously
but it's it's striking at the the heart
of which they're saying is that trans
people are responsible for making sure
that people don't hate them right it's
insane so that's number one really gross
I was banned from an event for being
transphobic and it's because transport
people are lame and nobody likes them
anyway
um
also I you know uh Matt Walsh level
analysis of what is a woman this one is
kind of just uh
this is the slam dunk in my opinion
transphobia I don't know what it is
that's just something I noticed was like
some part of transness also means
reinforcing gender stereotypes of degree
yeah rough do you wanna truth you wanna
really think and this is something I
just came to the realization this whole
like idea of like gender expression and
all this other stuff I don't give a [__]
it's whatever listen for me the whole
idea of gender has always been just
linked to biology that's how I've always
used it functionally right when I take
the idea that a woman is a woman what
I'm saying in that moment is like she
generally on average is going to be
physically smaller than men not as
strong as men capable of giving birth
you know ass and titties okay I'm gonna
look at those stuff that's always been
the functionality oh well I express like
listen when I say up women what I say
like that is I don't people who Express
we will have biological females
understanding so for me the idea of
Womanhood and femaleness have always
been interchangeable all this talk about
well the outfits I wear and the kind of
name like I don't give a [__] about none
of that [__] when I think about what a
woman is so you ask me from like when I
think of women's sports I don't think
about gender expression I just think
about their biology the old use of women
my whole life has just been for people
who are females so for me the two words
are pretty much the same thing to be
honest with you and by the way I I do
want to emphasize how coconuts and
Barbados preach is in most of these
clubs I'm telling you you guys have a
lot in common you might not want to uh
be aware so this is one of if I showed
this clip and said they're being
transphobic here's their response they
just laugh and be like walk off the
screen creaky ass [__] floor and then
they would move on and that's but let me
let me break it down for you guys okay
first of all this is three months ago
and this just occurred to them I find
that kind of funny I mean y'all made 30
videos about trans people and you still
don't know the difference between sex
and gender
and this is what I see Matt Walsh do and
the daily wire people do to make trans
people seem like freaks to make them
seem like they're psychotic like they're
super unreasonable
I don't know how it's not that hard to
understand the difference between sex
and gender it's just not well go ahead
well when he's going on and on about
like it doesn't [__] matter to me the
Nuance that exists in between like
gender like sure it doesn't matter to
you you know who it does matter to the
trans people who are trying to
understand how to be themselves publicly
when there are people like you who keep
telling the world to shut down those
conversations just because you don't
give a [__] about them you'll see that a
lot throughout this is that a lot of
there's like nobody cares about this and
what they mean is I don't care about it
yeah so just
yeah so again it's like
it's just the lowest level of
transphobic pandering sex and gender are
two different things are you guys
listening I'll explain it
sex is your biological
gender assigned at Birth there's female
and male and in some rare cases
um
uh intersex
okay
are we good with that we understand that
now you guys I mean this is pretty
simple stuff
okay
all right now let's go on to the more
the other part which I think you're
having a lot of trouble with gender
gender is how people Express themselves
as a social construct and on a spectrum
people identify
uh with different genders based on how
they feel and how they want to express
themselves do you see that they're two
different things
because to me it's just not that
complicated but yet somehow everyone who
wants to talk about trans people who's
conservative who wants to push
transphobia and just harvest the like
absolute lowest hanging fruit they
cannot accept this basic fact it's so
simple
people Express their gender in all
different kinds of ways and their sex
might be female they were born a woman
their gender they might Express as a man
does that make sense to you
it's really basic I don't know how to
break this down in any simpler terms for
them
um
so
uh that's that's I don't even really
don't know how to make break that down
for you anymore it's just like
intentionally obtuse we all know what a
woman is a woman is a woman a woman is a
woman with titties and ass
mm-hmm
love me a Woman except for the woman
that don't have titties but they're
still women okay so women what they're
not okay so then this so when does a
woman stop becoming a woman so they say
a woman's a woman everybody knows what a
woman is
so you say what if she had a a vasectomy
mastectomy
okay well she still has a vagina and a
uterus well what if uh if you say that
what he said titty's an ass
he said that he's an ass well ass is
kind of I mean men have ass so I'm not
really sure yeah
so if we remove the titties that's it
I'm now I'm just stumped guys both have
ass I don't know or guys and women both
have ass I don't know what to do with
this at this point
but uh yeah so this is like exactly what
you'll see is just what is a woman a
woman is a woman
you know what I mean I don't know what
else to say about that this is three
months ago too it's pretty wild
you see all kinds of comments too
uh oh okay can we fix the squeaking the
squeak in the floor man my guys
um if you look at the comma suit it's
just accessible with transphobia this is
not about trans people it's about people
abusing the loophole they're talking
about uh apparently there's a
a pandemic of men
lying about being trans to get into
prison and just have sex with all the
women prisoners
um
pandemic it's just it's uh it's all over
there lots of examples of that right I
mean it may be one two I don't know but
there's a lot of prisoners in America
the lack of trans men trying to get into
a man's prison is pretty telling of
what's actually going on there and again
this is something that happens too they
just make things with assumptions I
guarantee you there are trans men
uh trying to get into a Men's prison I
guarantee it
absolutely guarantee it
but this implies that it's like a it's
just a big game to trans people
they don't actually identify as a man
but when it comes you know when it comes
to something serious like prison and
then there'll be a woman
but anything else you know then they'll
be a man but that's that's actually not
how it is uh that's not how it is at all
there it is
so let's move it on to blatant misogyny
now you guys are gonna like this one
here he is a whole uh Mega compilation
of them uh laughing at feminists for
nothing
let's see
um I would yes an intersectional
feminist
[Laughter]
I've already identified which brought
I'm gonna eat the most are you feminist
yeah the best kind on a match today so
there it is it's like what what is she
saying she just said she's inter
intersectional which means
that they uh
they consider different types of
feminism by uh identity I guess
just more nuanced I I suppose I'm not
super familiar with feminist uh research
and Scholastics well like you said it's
the best kind it is the best kind which
is what she it seemed to indicate
the loser feminist researcher who spends
all her Day on Reddit boards and
successful research okay
so let's continue so that was apparently
funny and again that's that's just their
criticism of anyone
an intersection
she's dumb as [__] boy she is dumb
I've already identified which brought
I'm gonna hate the most tell you are you
feminist yeah the best kind on a match
today yeah
now what what is so funny to them that
she said yeah that's the way she said it
she just said yeah and they're like man
women are [__] stupid dude look at
this next part women are just so
annoying aren't they did you did you
hear the way she said yeah
he heard it's a blow up [__] doll
what's happening this is what this is
how I view women either you're bloat
[__] though
oh you're a feminist which choose your
lane [__]
I was about ready
back are you hoping if I didn't hush
today yeah
why why are you doing this Jubilee
you're doing this on purpose are you
guys a men's rights channel are you guys
low-key just finding the most detestable
ladies to do this so his his theory is
because she said yeah in a way that he
thought was annoying is actually a in
Disguise men's rights Channel because
she's so hateable obviously
by the way she's showing enthusiasm
she's there to make a match you know
what I mean she wasn't like no I don't
like a men are just the worst and it's
so hard to match with them look at you
guys y'all are [__] like
so mask off here the testable ladies
what is distestable about saying yeah in
an enthused way
like what this
yeah yeah dude I'm a spatula I don't
know like what about you and be like I
want to be a little spoon
dude is that the floor yeah no that's
Jesus yeah no they're they're floors
creepy so loud what's going on it's
Hollow under there there's bodies or
something
can you come Zach cut the creaking I
mean this is a serious production here
you know what I mean
what could cause a floorboard that
creaky and it's been like that for years
apparently and they've refused to uh fix
it
cheap flooring just or no not even or
just an old house just an old house Our
House Michigan that creaky oh it's it's
yeah our house was built in like 1920s
so okay so I guess there's salt to the
Earth then we love the creaky
floorboards uh we love them folks
although a couple of real men like you I
think would have resolved that issue by
now
yeah
please
sorry
not what I told you [__] about
how women suck at lines and like making
the first move like they they're
terrible but it's okay so let me do
something but holy [__] when I was on
these dating apps and we would meet the
first time Creek potentially uh
um having Creek
not bad uh that's pretty good the creek
talks more than preach so that's true
yeah maybe they should rename it that's
true in fact I don't know what you're
paying preach but you could just sub him
out just put a blow up [__] doll that
looks like him and let the creek do the
talking you know
says it says you know
as good of an input as he has since I'm
telling you it was garbage garbage
jokes that are harmful jokes are not
healthy because they just lead to people
normalizing things people always say oh
it's just a joke but when someone else
hears it they don't realize how that
resonates and again how that turns into
violence I always have to repeat this
feminists
you guys can't cherry pick when you guys
like science and when you don't if you
believe in science on climate change you
have to believe the conclusive science
on this one fact okay
jokes do not lead to violence the
science is conclusive on the fact that
video games does not lead to violence I
really like to preach's input on this
one though it was really insightful wow
uh coconuts and Barbados what would you
have to say in a to back up our boy
Babel here
just a creek all right he gets the job
he's in actually not to not to interrupt
this is one of my favorite takes of
theirs so let me go back you guys can
enjoy it normalizing things people
always say oh it's just a joke but when
someone else hears it they don't realize
how that resonates and again how that
turns into violence I always have to
repeat this feminists
here we go you listen up feminist loser
this is for you you idiot yes she's the
loser feminist threesome all right I'm
ready just listen hard because I know
you don't think so good yeah jump
started dummy it's got to be so quiet
before I get ready when you guys like
science and when you don't if you
believe in science on climate change you
have to believe the conclusive signs on
this one fact okay
to violence the science is conclusive on
the fact that video games does not lead
to violence it does not lead to
normalization you guys have to stop
making this correlation because the
science is against you you can't say
science is right on one point and then
you dismiss the science on a point
that's convenient for you you know who I
did so this is incredible
he says if you believe in climate change
then you must believe that all jokes
about anything all the time are okay or
your anti-science the [__]
and uh I found that really interesting
so I started Googling around for the
studies that prove that jokes do not
have any impact increasing uh violence
or misogyny it's proven by science it's
proven by science conclusively
conclusively this is peer-reviewed they
saw it they saw the signs there must be
something wrong with Google because I
couldn't find any studies that said that
it's really weird
just on face if you're a thinking person
you know that you can't like it'd be
possible to run a [__]
well researched uh experiment about
jokes leading to violence it's so Broad
and by the way it's just not true right
and I'm a comedian saying that
extremists uh it's a well-known tactic
where they got they
mask really extremist things as jokes to
probe the limit of what they can get
away with saying oh I was just kidding
let's kill all the Jews just kidding you
know what I mean blackface I mean uh
that some people would say blackface is
just a joke right oh man I mean it's
just a joke jokes are cool what about
like uh
hey you you don't be really funny if I
went up into the local middle school and
just got weird and wild over there with
you know first second amendment stuff
I don't know I'm just saying like Joe
like you can't say scientifically
jokes don't lead to violence I mean
that's so stupid and then he says
just like video games don't lead to
violence and
I mean there have been studies on that
and that that is true but that isn't
really relevant but well it's not at all
relevant does he think that jokes is the
same thing as video games because I'd be
concerned about his mental capacity I
don't I'm not sure what what that aside
was supposed to jokes are video games
I don't get it it's really insanely and
this isn't the first time he does this
isn't the only time he does three goes
science proves this thing
that has absolutely no basis or backing
and actually on face is silly uh you
know if you just use a little bit of
logic so what the [__] are you talking
about bro
you know
hey dude I got this really funny joke
did you hear the one about the uh see I
can't even do there's so many horrible
racist jokes I mean there's so many
thank you yeah
Chris Rock's joke led to violence what
about that
I mean in a sense I know in a sense that
man told a joke he got slapped in the
face I think that's that disproves your
theory
you know what I mean and it wasn't
really even an offensive joke really uh
that bad I didn't think so what do you
guys think about that Babylon Creek
yeah reach might be too generous he
literally hasn't said a single [__]
word so far in all this [__] he just
goes wow wow we watched a bunch of
videos he talks plenty it's just he's
Abba usually has the spicier tick it
seems awesome he just goes wow man
yeah I mean listen
jokes can serve to dehumanize groups of
people
that's probably a better known
phenomenon if you look at uh instances
of go take a look at some of the jokes
about Jews in Nazi Germany or jokes
about you know African Americans during
Jim Crow or slavery they serve
extremists as a method to dehumanize
people that that allows uh violence
against them you know
it's stupid what do you [__] why would
you even say that it's so dumb bro
yeah but go ahead and cite me the study
that says jokes are cool bro no matter
what they are about anything all the
time no matter what
uh Chris Rock your thoughts
[Music]
just a creek
okay that's all Chris Rock has to say
about that
uh you want to say you can go ahead and
say that I was gonna say an example in
my own family my brother was bullied you
know badly for being Arab after 9 11 and
my brother is white passing you know he
doesn't even look Arab and he was like
really significantly bullied a lot in
elementary school and middle school did
he consider that they were just jokes
and jokes have no impact on anything
ever uh no he had to go to a therapist
well what an idiot lose money on that he
could have watched their video yeah oh I
was bullied because I had and I mean
there were lots of hate crimes against
Muslim Americans during that time oh
yeah oh yeah yeah you know even today
there still is you know there's a uh a
guy wearing a trump hat who punched a
Muslim lady in the head at the hospital
um in our hometown Jesus for no reason I
wonder what it was yeah I mean you see
the same thing with shop Asian hate yeah
during the pandemic there people are
like blaming flu on
Chinese people and
there was lots of kung flu that's a joke
right Kung Fu so if you say so I mean
huge uh
uh surge in violence uh hate crimes
against um you know they make a lot of
joke about trans people actually on
their on their program and uh there's a
huge surge in hate crimes and violence
against trans people I'm just saying
they go come on dude shut the [__] up
stop it
you're being silly against you you can't
say science is right on one point and
then you dismiss the science on a point
that's convenient if you believe in
climate change I just what the [__]
if you believe in climate change you
stupid feminist
then you for sure believe that all jokes
are okay no matter what you know who I
didn't hear from this entire time in
Ukraine in this whole conflict who
feminists
uh
he was on the lookout were you looking
you know who didn't approach me and
complain about uh Ukrainian women loser
feminists he's on the forums
this steak is
them I was working with uh someone who I
just started working with who's a
Ukrainian Refugee and she sent me this
clip because it it you know pissed her
off so much so this is this one is
really good that's that's right yeah
yeah when all the women were getting on
them trains with them old [__] right
and the men had to stay behind because
you were between the ages of 18 to 65.
crickets I hear single feminists say
freaking we want to be in equal footing
with the men staying at the front line I
didn't hear a single one drinking were
you listening I just can't get over the
fact that they always make this
assumption that they know everything
about everything just because they say
so
yeah no we we pulled everyone and we
were listening and we didn't hear any
feminists saying anything about anything
you never notice it's always about equal
rights equal representation well [__]
get on the front lines and grab a rifle
uh I got a trade ticket to catch I gotta
cook dinner I gotta yeah so I mean again
this is a funny joke right
about Ukrainian women not basically
fleeing the country and of course
they're wrong as they are about most
things they just say speak out their ass
I mean Ukrainian women are playing a
huge and vital role
and the Ukrainian military 60 000 women
both fight both in in roles of fighting
okay who you're quick to just [__]
like [__] good on the train I mean
these women are fighting for their
freedom for their lives and uh well the
women just aren't doing enough because
feminism now the women are actually uh
doing invaluable roles uh in the
Ukrainian armor Army and the Army effort
so
what's the deal here dude what I don't
understand the point of the joke
is this in a cream is this a Ukrainian
Army a military member female
is that what I'm seeing there
that can't be right because I heard the
feminists I didn't hear anything I
didn't hear anything no they're on the
trains okay they're on the lookout yeah
I hear it I didn't hear I was listening
I was listening for them I guess they
were busy fighting for their [__]
freedom
they're actually actually busy dude they
[__] losers
I mean you know what I'm saying you're
gonna tell me you're not misogynistic
you're a [__] loser bro thinly veiled
red pills is all you are
you know you guys are like just
literally fresh and fit minus the end
selling you're like fresh and Fit Plus
you know what I mean
come on dude
stop diet fresh and fit you guys are
wish store fresh and fresh in a bit
fresh and fresh in a bit
yeah
so yeah again a woman who I work with
who's your Ukrainian Refugee saw this
and was like what the [__] like I have
women tons of friends first of all and a
clump and uh everyone I know first of
all is suffering dying bleeding fighting
in this war and lots of women too who
they're quick to just be like NAB get on
the train [__] feminist
loser feminist idiot
be in the kitchen hey baby you got my
apron I got a drink to catch
they're just jokes though so as they as
they mentioned
jokes are
cool
in any context all the time no matter
what oh what's interesting though is
that you know there is a lot of like
Russian and conservative propaganda
against
root Ukrainian people
and uh I don't think this is very far
adjacent
from it I'll just stay here with the
kids yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah guys guys
listen listen I heard they got a home in
Poland I need some cleaning I'm out this
[__]
yeah
they're just making up scenarios it's
pretty incredible like you guys don't
know [__] anything about Ukraine
oh [__] what'd I do
you never notice it's always about equal
rights equal representation
you you go to war I just stay here with
the kids yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
guys guys listen listen I heard they got
a home in Poland I need some cleaning
I'm out this [__] oh it's over yeah I
gotta go clean a house bye guys feminism
yeah because fleeing to safety isn't
difficult it's actually uh
it's a woman thing yeah I know it's true
it's an easy thing that just the yeah
Julie said I'm polished we have a huge
amount of Ukrainian refugees most of the
women who flee have children and they
want to protect them often they leave
the children here with the family and go
back and fight nah that sounds like
propaganda [__] to me
so you're telling me the women
feminist losers flee
that you people like Olivia
they flee they go to Ukraine leave the
kids in safety
okay cowards losers idiots feminists and
then they're just on Reddit the whole
time and then they go on Reddit and
complain the loser feminist researchers
and then they go back to Ukraine to help
with the war efforts what would you guys
prefer if the kids just stayed there and
got bombed
uh real feminists real feminists who
believe in real equality leave their
kids there to get bombed while they
fight on the front line
okay guys interesting Theory
I love that I I find it so funny that
they call you a femis though and I know
that's not an insult but they they use
them it is they use it as an instrument
so what about you makes you like a
feminist that you're a young girl that
doesn't suffer fools I think that makes
you a feminist that like a lot of people
like to weaponize
um me being on this show as um you just
wanting a woman here and like that's I'm
just filling a role and like it just so
happens that I'm here and I didn't do it
right and that's what like the argument
is being made and I think that them just
calling me a feminist is being like Oh
[__] like the feminist Tire you know
what I'm saying
it's just I think it really says a lot
about their world view for them to just
write you off as a feminist like you
don't sit here and talk about women's
rights all day no or about women's
rights in fact I don't think I've ever
heard you do that so you're just
basically like a typical are you a
Zoomer yeah your typical woman Zoomer
and so they see that yeah I'm sorry you
guys as you're the enemy bro yeah you're
the enemy everything I represent
sorry guys loser loser loser Reddit
researcher so at this point you guys
really uh I'm sorry but you guys are
misogynist I'm sorry it's just no way to
deny it I mean you guys just
you guys just have a problem with women
or at least you're pandering to your
audience that too
you know
taboo subjects they telling it like it
is brother that's so true you don't want
to hear it I don't want to hear it but
but I need to be told I need to be told
you do need to be told and it's it's a
tab okay uh what's that creaking please
can you
you know what topic has just gone way
too long without being addressed women
being annoying that is that's taboo yeah
it's a taboo subject and let's talk
about it
they're breaking the the glass ceiling
here have we ever discussed this um
this phenomenon of women be shopping
yo wait
they do be they'd like for real I do be
doing that yeah
all right now this part we're going to
move on to this permaband hypocrisy
which I love they actually were
advocating for yours truly to be
permanently banned from YouTube what for
what
for what
what well let's see
here's what's crazy
hit me with that that's that creaky [__]
bro
come on bro come on
was that uh was that
preach talking or was that the
floorboard I can't tell anymore
you remember when he had his one weak
man yeah Ethan class should be Parma
band why
the man docked someone on a live
that's all that God I like the [__] I
like to know who this guy is man
I know who is does he have an online
Persona no he's a producer I mean okay
if you don't know who Olivia is she's
the loser feminist researcher who spends
all her Day on Reddit boards
he knows a lot about my girl yeah loser
feminist
girl give me a better selfie if you're
gonna put one in also you look good I
hate that one people on Reddit like to
use that one why they always that is
such a flex if that's your worst photo
that is so kind of you to say definitely
I've got that like goofy I can't even
look at her okay so the way she found
this dude's name who they incorrectly
doxed and she went on a Reddit post and
looked at the comments and then found
his name and think that was reliable
information
keep in mind this is one of the largest
podcasts on YouTube thank you for
acknowledging that are they running
Amen brother someone called me on
Twitter today a twink
that got me going that I'm still I'm
still riding that high
still riding that time
the number one podcast in the world
Uncle Howie baby
yeah so okay so research Department well
let's Carry On music okay I'll just let
it play producer
yeah God I hope that man's life is
ruined for this I hope so too oh someone
says why you abuse uh uh protecting his
identity I don't give a [__] I don't
give me
yeah I don't give a [__] I want this
guy's life run are you kidding me okay
first of all they mute the name that is
his name yes first of all
they also have a tendency of like
building up uh this whole like uh
mythology of something small I did and
then every episode they talk about it it
gets worse and worse and worse this is
one of the things so what happened is I
really [__] up and I feel horrible
horror that UF
answer for this mistake that I made the
name was correct I said the wrong
occupation which was horrible and
shouldn't have happened and we quickly
corrected it and I apologized and I will
forever be making up for it
hate that mistake I cringe every day
about it I'm a loser feminist I wish you
could see Olivia when we were playing
that clip right now she was going like
this and I okay listen yeah we all make
mistakes
but do we actually know what doxing is
like that's a pretty serious
dude what the [__] do you know what like
we said the name which was his name and
his occupation we never showed his
Instagram page we said what business he
was in and it was wrong me we never
showed
his Instagram page no okay or his face
did we show his face or anything like
that no we didn't show anything
you say the handle
Instagram handle
I I I don't remember but I don't think
you did I think I don't think so you you
described him described the wrong person
and then people may have gone and found
the wrong person so but the interesting
part is besides not showing his
Instagram or his picture or anything we
immediately corrected the record
and we even talked to the guy during the
same episode cleared it all up no foul
he went to high school with my sister oh
is that right yes he's very nice
and then I think he even said something
like thanks for all the love H3 and it
was like yeah yeah yeah I was all posted
on his story so like as far as doxing
goes
I'm having a hard time getting what you
did to yourself the other week was uh
that was doxing when I showed my phone
your phone number four times in a row or
whatever it was but like so that's a
permanent ban I mean just for saying the
right name but the wrong occupation
and it wasn't good I think not we all
acknowledge that but I feel like we we
did we did good in in uh doing the right
thing immediately and recovering yeah
the only person you've doxed is yourself
and that's the way it should be all day
every day
shout out to members who get my personal
phone number
I'll be dropping my new phone number
next Tuesday
okay so listen I if I should be
permanently banned for that
then I got an issue with them hmm
oh they actually have this to say too
which is pretty pretty fun here I'll
just play but it's not unexpected
because of what I expect from the H3 HD
band the same people who falsely accuse
other people or docks people for fun
like this is what the kind of stuff that
they do wrong like you talk about these
guys are such cowards like bro you were
doxing people you should be banned on
this platform did you forget that you
just docs to random person online for no
reason
then you sat there afterwards and
brought this false accuser against
friendship fit just because you hate
them like how you gonna call me a scum
and a coward some [__] as you
see as he continues to talk about it
it's this mythology of oh you doc
someone for no reason
what for fun for fun for fun
it was fun you loved it you do it
because it's just part of your persona
Ethan Klein he's just dachshund people
okay so
now let's let's talk about you guys now
that we've addressed that because I
think we're gonna have a problem here
now I'm gonna talk about this more later
but some of you may remember there was a
19 year old girl
who reached out to us and said she had a
terrible date with Myron a fresh and fit
we vetted her heavily
just to confirm that this date did
happen and that she was at his house and
all this stuff we we confirmed that so
we knew she wasn't just making [__] up
and when she called in
um
she basically just described their bad
date
and at one point she said that he lifted
up her top to see her breasts and then
he made some negative comment about her
breasts and I didn't know that but at
the moment I was like oh that sounds
like possibly assault
that was the only time I brought it up
in the interview
and so we're again we're going to get
into the specific specifics of that but
they went on this whole Crusade not just
against me but specifically about the 19
year old girl who they called a liar
like disgusting I mean they said they
were really going on about this girl
okay
uh here's what here's what they said
about this 19 year old girl and even if
you called in to describe her bad date
with Myron
you tell me where's the malice okay go
ahead and that's the thing you could
have just said that you could have just
said that even if he said that
he said that he made a comment about
your boobies
was it worth all the LIE
all of that now you just look stupid
Danielle
yeah I'm saying your name because
[__] have to know your name the
same way you try to frame a [__]
like that people need to know who the
[__] you are yeah just so they know that
you're a piece of [__] you want to frame
them as a piece of [__] but the bigger
the biggest piece of [__] in this story
is you it's you it's you my girl you and
Ethan Klein who didn't even say anything
like what you were a big ass loser
that's you you want a frame is that a
big loser it's all you
okay so thank you for the contribution
by the way from preach on that one who
says let's let her her picture by the
way is in this thumbnail
I don't need to show it because there's
no reason to even make her further
subject
but her face is prominently detailed
in the thumbnail
and and he's literally saying people
need to know your name
what the [__] now this is malicious
toxic you showed her face and her name
which wasn't public
that's toxic
you making private information public
with a malicious intent now tell me
which is worse now wait till I get into
the actual facts of this the basis of
this or this just just onslaught of
horrible things they're saying about her
it's a whole bunch of silly [__]
nonsense because at the end of the day
Myron admits to the worst part
huh and we'll get into all that later
but you tell me what the [__] is worse
bro
I mean what
that's actually nauseating what he did
here it's dangerous and it's [__] up
sending a straight up Army of angry you
know feminist hating men to go harass
her
I should be I should be kicked off
YouTube for doxing go ahead AV
oh nothing no I'm just I was agreeing
with you oh thank you for agreeing
uh so you know what I mean
that shit's [__] nasty nasty Behavior
and by the way they're talking about
Myron a 35 year old man
trying to [__] a 19 year old who they
don't like and make fun of all the time
but
when when an accuser comes along
solidarity
solidarity my brothers dudes Rock I hate
them but you know what I hate worse
feminists
we can lock arms in that that me up
very interesting isn't it so people are
saying why why do they immediately
assuming that she's lying well I'll go
over that the reasons are absurd like
absurd
and you know what my only regret
honestly and this is not defending her
sooner because the way that they [__]
went after her for that call was
unforgivable I mean just [__]
she didn't deserve any of that man
oh so there it is here's fresh and fit
who uh I mean you know I get them mixed
up they're so they really are so similar
um
here is the anti-doxing Crusaders
Babylon reach one more time for the
people in back the same way you try to
frame a [__] all the LIE
all of that now you just look stupid
Danielle
yeah he's also he's also implying here
which that she did it she's lying
specifically
because he made fun of her boobies
right that's pretty interesting it's
also I mean you did suggest as a
question uh during when you were
speaking to her like that sounds kind of
like assault is what you said yeah and
she immediately said no and so when he's
talking about frame them there was no
framing there wasn't really even a crime
alleged it was just he's an embarrassing
loser was kind of like the thrust of the
call and who's framing when they're
titling their video fake me too
allegations when that was an allegations
it wasn't a me too allegation it was I
went on a pseudo date with this [__]
weirdo right and it was a horrible
experience also like this guy who's like
obsessed with being an alpha has no game
at all like no game right that to me is
funny and that's the real irony and the
reason we found it interesting is he's
giving dating advice but he's zero games
Zero game negative Christmas and so um
anyway we'll get more into that later
we'll talk about that whole Saga but
here they are saying she lied
because he made fun of her boobies which
of course you know feminists do they
they just lie about essay for Revenge
you know like women do boobies
was it
he said that he made you look at you
crazy now it's gymnastics bro and that's
the thing you could have just said that
you could have just said that and even
if he said that
he said that he made a comment about
your boobies
was it worth all the lie I mean right
he's implying he said that
and then you lied
was it worth it okay
we'll get it more into that later but
y'all are killing it
y'all are just killing it hmm
love to see it
people need to know her name so nasty
you should pull that
you know
and by the way just to compare
amaranth's husband or ex-husband I don't
know what the status is
was physically or I don't know
physically but like the abuse that she
was
uh undergoing the control was insane and
it was taking place live so yeah that
guy is a [__] giant piece of [__]
well that's where the problem is you
were you were worked up because you were
defending a woman in the moment where
they're defending a man so
oh and that guy that listen that guy was
is guilty as [__] okay [__] him like
it's on video
now we got this and again not we're not
defending the mistake Olivia and Ethan
both acknowledged that that was bad and
then and now then and now in the moment
reached out to the person that was
mistakenly identified apologized uh I
don't I suspect nothing like that has
occurred on their end with uh this girl
no
no they're leading with malice right
their intent is malice one more time I
didn't play it just so you guys get the
impact of this how fun you made a
comment about your boobies
was it worth all the LIE
all of that now you just look stupid
Danielle yeah I'm saying your name
because [__] have to know your
name the same way you try to frame a
[__] like that people need to
know who the [__] you are yeah just so
they know
you a piece of [__] you want to frame
them as a piece of [__] but the bigger
pit the biggest piece of [__] in this
story is you and her face zoomed in
prominently featured on the thumbnail
awesome
really cool guys
uh so we'll get into that but good job
sending a mob of angry Mentor harass a
19 year old
you know listen if you think 19 year
olds act wild and are immature then as a
35 year old
maybe they'll date them
my advice
all right so now we're gonna get into
this section called defending awful
people where I think this shows
basically
their bad faith attempts uh when talking
about me when that in any situation even
situations where I'm like
indisputably correct
that somehow they managed to take the
side of the person opposing me no matter
how obscene it is right only because
they think they know that you know
Pro H or anti-h3 hate videos get the
Fallen fan click people love H3 yeah
they love it so you know kill it brother
but don't [__] but you're you're not
being honest here they are defending my
boys
my boys are defending yes
Stephen Crowder
well again not defending but they're
saying that we look equally stupid so
you were asking myself
it doesn't work either it's giving me uh
critical hit me with that critical I
love that one
I see a lot of people don't like Ethan
and that's totally fine you don't have
to like everyone or anything it's worse
than that but yeah Charlie wasn't as bad
Charlie's not that bad we love Charlie
don't we folks
here it is it's on the whole thing is I
want to go watch and I couldn't stop
Chad laughing and I'll be honest with
you I think
if you're gonna accept the debate with
somebody you can't switch yourself out
for somebody else Steve's against the
rules against the rules mods mods
mods he broke the rules and it's so
funny to me that again it's like the
sanctity of debate argument uh but
you'll see he contradicts himself later
it's so stupid the Spartans are
that they are like uh practice man love
with children oh geez by the way I do
think that's still a well-made point the
man has a Spartan [__] yeah thing on
his desk and he's like you know if
you're worried about man love let's
start there brother
but okay that's that's neither here nor
there okay so this is what's gonna
happen what did I tell you he was going
to do anything he could to avoid oh oh
there he is oh no
internet history I knew in the moment
I'm when I was sitting there I'm like
this is [__] history try to say this
isn't funny come on this is me looking
like an idiot apparently in their eyes
well slimy
for again the same I guess slimy okay
yeah uh against against well-established
rules for debate against the courageous
ever moral
uh racist the increa you know Stephen
Crowder shall never be slighted [__]
watch it no I know I'm being careful
Stephen
got
started was caught on video abusing his
wife and having a meltdown four days
later
I we ruined his life bro that's a dub
Sam sear called it and his response he
said this is where your life starts to
fall apart he was right he was totally
[__] that's crazy
he said look me in my eyes Stephen it
all falls apart here how did he know now
I see why all the conservatives are so
scared of Sam he's the king Slayer
Velveteen Rabbit those Velveteen Rabbit
eyes still trying to decode that one
foreign
some type of way off the top yeah that
was the point dumbass that was the whole
[__] point because Crowders a
detestable human being we don't respect
him I don't exactly be a debate I
literally don't respect him and the
whole premise of him challenging me to a
debate was silly because I'm not a
political commentator i i people know
that I'm a comedian I don't know [__]
about I don't know nothing about nobody
and so the whole premise of him wanting
to debate me was what as he said oh it's
just gonna be an easy layup so you know
the man he he fell to his own hubris to
his own arrogance he got on a call with
me I don't respect him and of course I
did a ruse [__] him and [__] you guys
too actually
you got tricked yeah like why would you
do as Crowder put it based off a lot bro
you never you've never done a goof what
about a I thought jokes were harmless
this is a joke it's a joke bro an
interesting point it's just so [__]
joke uh scientifically it's been studied
that um violating the rules of debate
actually leads to real world violence so
maybe check yourself [__] yeah
oh no
actually violating the rules of uh the
sanctity of debate actually leads to
people liking trans people less
so um
transfer Transit trans
correct Fair which no inquires defense I
I do think that was a slimy move like
and I think Ethan when they were kind of
having the conversation I was watching I
was like do you guys not recognize how
slimy that looks yeah yeah dude yes it
was the intention the whole time we
loved it
scheming I was scheming for weeks you
know what I mean we even had Sam record
a fake episode to go live to trick
Crowder we were scheming and scheming
the Slime was oozing out of my board and
slime I love it I love it don't you
think Ethan it was just a little bit
inconsiderate of you
I mean please spare poor Crowder uh we
shouldn't and bear we don't lie
we did not tell lies to Stephen Crowder
how dare you
okay why does it lie
like how smarmy you were being the whole
time like listen you need some people
around you to tell you you're being a
little bit ridiculous in that moment
he's attacking you guys now boy what
other show does the crew have a button
to silence the host yeah
oh I tell Ethan he's me I tell Ethan
he's being ridiculous pretty much on a
daily basis here on this show yeah
um so but that's okay they don't watch
every episode don't expect them to know
that
uh you needed a room full of people to
tell you not to be a meanie to Crowder
because Crowder deserves respect yeah
he deserves to have a clean
sanctimonious debate sanctimonious yeah
and I've seen the science
the science backs that up yeah the
science backs up that Crowder needs that
he needs to think a sink a debate that
follows the Saints to D of regular it's
just I love that we
it's a really an effort here to
highlight
they really are good at this air this
smugness of just being above everything
uh and just they're always right about
everything that seems to be the vibe but
they're really just morons and they're
hateful morons they're hateful bigoted
morons
and uh they're pandering
they're not serious and they're bad
faith just like I said last week
but I'll continue because it gets better
all right now okay so so now that
they've criticized me
that they go on because they don't like
Steven Crowder either right
they gotta keep it real and criticize
both sides now here
they explain exactly why I was justified
in doing a ruse on Steven listen to this
yo I'm gonna be honest with you guys
this whole like internet war base is the
most corny [__] on the [__] this is not
the right uh link give me one sec
uh
it's in that same video here it is yeah
here it is so here they go Hall to fame
is a is a series called change my mind
where you go on college campuses with
your binder full of facts okay
and then you just railroad people
strangers with zero following because
and here you have somebody who's
you know knows their stuff who follows
the lingo Who falls who has a you know
yeah I think he has like a million Subs
the same Cedar you know majority report
and
you won't do it Stephen Curry and I'm
just like what why would you go out of
your way to debate people who clearly
don't know the subject matter but then
you have somebody who does and you're
like I refuse to do it ever but we've
been saying that it was this in general
isn't the way that you would that he was
doing thing was a bit like
hey
that that's another one of those
arguments that very strong point but I I
have to pull back my battle there that's
amazing I'm telling you when you watch
their videos they deliver a lot of their
most poignant uh arguments in such a
laughter after stuttering for like 10
seconds and then hit him with the ass
how do I criticize him in a succinct
nailed it bro or uh speaking of
floorboard you know it's interesting
though because everything that ABBA said
prior to that it sounds like you get it
like that's exactly why we did it eggs
that explains why what I did was so
funny it was a good joke because of
everything you just described but
because they're so bad faith they're so
desperate to appeal to the Fallen fan
that they can't possibly ever take my
side on anything uh that they've they've
wrapped themselves into a pretzel on one
hand saying that I'm a coward and slimy
and on the other hand it perfectly
explaining why what I did was justified
ah it was a bit slimy and stuff like
that now you just prove it now you
really just want to battle people that
don't have a following so that you're
doing this Engine with stuff and that is
blown out of proportion people know it
is that how is that you totally get me
what you want to get someone that has a
less substantially less following than
you so that if ever you say something
that's out of hand it doesn't get
exposed like that yeah right but when
you're going to get someone that has
equal following as you then you you're
gonna be like nah you know what yeah you
guys totally get me man it's incredible
it's like we're aligned awesome
although did you consider this counter
argument
that puts things in perspective
you know what I mean
moving on
uh also interestingly
this this line I just thought was kind
of funny I mean
sounds like fuel yeah I'm gonna be
honest with you guys this whole like
internet War beef is the most corny [__]
on the [__] planet like I know
sometimes we've been like covering
people multiple times and be like oh
there's a beef we just cover it because
it's relevant and people want to see it
people think going back and forth is
just a war like I don't know to me
that's just a cringy language like
people use the most violent oh I got
bear smoke for them intellectually like
kill yourself actually kill yourself by
the way this man told me to kill myself
and he bleeped the kill like what kind
of [__] ass [__] loser are you just
say it you [__] [__] if you're gonna
tell someone to kill themselves don't
bleep the kill just back it up oh
YouTube's gonna demonstrate shut the
[__] up bro
own it it's ugly you're disgusting I'm
gonna kill you you know yeah so Dr
Phil's got kahunes
so you should be permaband right you
should be a Perma band for a mistake
that you clarified but but it's okay for
them to say [__] like that kill yourself
I think that's T well I don't know we
don't know that they said kill right
here I have to say this I'm not saying
it should be banned I'm just saying the
irony is uh interesting yeah look
I don't care that they told me to kill
myself I just think it's [__]
embarrassing and this God the Lord's
year this was five days ago the Lord's
year of 2023 you're on YouTube saying
kill yourself like bro it's time to grow
the [__] up okay
you know
but believe but don't bleep The Kill
do us all a favor
she's such a big we don't know he said
here you know
you know
hey I get in trouble all the time I got
a button at least I say what I mean
[__]
you'll see me bleeping words I just hit
the whole damn button I'm a kid all
right chill Dr Phil it's not that
serious
yeah coward loser dummy [__] idiot
[__] [__] [__]
[__] dumbass so that was funny and then
at the same time they're like debate is
so silly it's so silly
uh but you know when it comes to Ethan
and Crowder it's a holy sacred thing
that we cannot possibly destroy uh you
know anyway so now we're gonna go on
to potentially the biggest reach they're
gonna defend Sebastian The Tick Tock
alpha male
who by all accounts was
came on the show and eviscerated you
know and I'm not too my own horn here
maybe I am a little bit all right you've
got to take listen you got to take your
dubs where you can get them but
they saw that and said oh no Ethan's the
one that's embarrassing in their video
titled Ethan's embarrassing I just want
to be left alone
so let's see here yeah I know I'm sorry
I'm sorry to keep bringing you up
brother just hold on okay
won't be left alone
um that's like one of my favorites
so they removed so here's the thing
that's interesting and talking about
this
they remove the entire
heart of the conversation and straw man
my whole argument
the basis of this conversation was
Sebastian started from a tick tock in
which he said
my woman should not dress sexy unless
she's with me
which I found to be
a loser-ish thing to say
and I even say it here
uh because he starts to walk that back
okay during this conversation you can
see it right here
what's the problem
well it just it's a little insecure
no it's not it is a little it's a
preference
well in this video because you're kind
of walking it back so we can move on if
you want but so I says that you're
walking it back so the conversations
kind of move and we can move on but we
continue to talk about they they removed
the context which I think
shows the whole basis of their
conversation and instead of that they
make they try to present this opinion
which I do not have which is that
partners aren't allowed to set
boundaries and if you're
you need to let your significant other
wear whatever they want all the time or
you're insecure which was obviously not
my point
like clearly you know I mean that's
that's silly
but uh that doesn't keep them from
taking it out of context and being bad
faith actors
and giant uh losers here it is
Genesis for this was he put out a video
on Tick Tock like uh
something about like how women should
dress yeah
what no no no no no no stop stop you see
the way he remixes it
[Applause]
so they're doing it again
uh there's the original Tick Tock that's
what I said he said if I'm with a girl
he didn't tell other people how they
have to dress he didn't tell women what
they have to do every day yeah I didn't
do that either nowhere and so they set
up this whole straw man argue against
something I never said or claimed or
think uh then they go oh look at idiot
look at Ethan he's such an idiot he's
not telling everyone get an open
relationship he's saying I like all
relationships that's okay I want to run
my ownership this way which is okay you
listen this is so stupid the way two
people want to legislate their
relationship and the boundaries within
them is between the two people yeah
of course right why would I disagree
with that you dumb it's like bro just
engage with me honestly if you wanna
actually
you know but they don't want to do that
even when there was me I wouldn't want
them to do that in public okay
okay
what's the problem well it's just it's a
little insecure listen people know dude
okay so without the context now here
uh here let me keep playing it actually
didn't he say he's going to go back and
play the original Tick Tock he said that
right did I show that part
no no you have not shown that okay okay
so thank you based off the kind of
things that they wear they're gonna get
a different reception from people yeah
if I'm with a woman yeah and she's out
here dressed like she's going to Cancun
tomorrow I'm gonna feel a little bit
like that she is off not because it
makes me like you're inside he is
insecure by the way and there's nothing
wrong with that you know it's okay to
feel insecure and you work with your
partner
but anyway that's not the point here but
he is insecure both of them are deeply
deeply
actually you know what I think they have
they have issues but they strike me as
confident too to be honest with you guys
confidently wrong confidently stupid
confidently hateful bigots you're you're
100 insecure then yeah you can't handle
it dude
the things that they wear they're gonna
get a different reception from people
yeah if I'm a with a woman and she's out
here dressed like she's going to Cancun
tomorrow I'm gonna feel a little bit
like that she is off yeah yep that's
your problem
look it's your preference if you don't
want to be with a girl who's comfortable
doing that right but the but the
underlying emotion which was try I was
trying to coax out with Sebastian is
that what is that feeling of feeling off
it's disgust
I love this
Ah that's a crazy thing to say it's
disgust okay loser
these guys are so desperate to prove
they're not insecure they're like no
when it's disgusting when I see a
woman's cleavage disgusting it makes me
wanna
it makes me wanna
it makes it makes me want to circumcise
their vagina
it makes it makes me want to mutilate
their genitals what do you mean
disgusted chill out dude I think it's
disgusting when someone wants to be that
trashy looking okay now the context of
this is really important now as we're
talking
um
because we said we cannot
uh
hold on I'm a little off
because we say that you know
[__] or dressing like a hoe as
Sebastian said is pretty subjective I
mean so we said we use this because it's
your purpose
as an agreeable starting point you don't
want to be with a girl who's comfortable
doing that right but the but the
underlying what the [__] hold on these
links are all crazy
[Music]
yeah thank you that's what my that's
what's going on in my brain we're
vamping with the with the sweet yeah
we're riffing hold on
I don't know if I got the wrong URLs
here
okay let me go back and try
[Music]
okay
let's start over he's gonna show this
and be like he does look he's just
fluttered
I just got the wrong URL bro we got it
you know what I mean let's start over
let's so here
I called him out for not walking back
his argument
here he apparently let me pull this one
up again because I missed Genesis for
this was he put out a video on Tick Tock
like uh
something about like how women should
dress
yeah
what no no no no no no stop okay yes
yeah yeah so this is what I wanted to
show you the way he remixes it
is
I'm playing the original Tick Tock
that's what I said he said so he says
I'll play the original Tick Tock notice
he does not play the original Tick Tock
actually he uh he does not but I will
because I'm not a coward and I actually
would like to engage with the facts of
this conversation and not be a little
[__]
that just wants to get hate views off of
off of me so let's go ahead and see
the original tick tock
of this dude he's defending if you're
doing so here's your boy uh Sebastian
the girl is there a thing she can and
cannot wear if she's dressed
provocatively and I'm not with her
there's absolutely no reason why she
should be dressed that way you should
only care about my time if you're my
wife there should be no other attention
from a man that you should care about
other than mine why would you wear a
dress that makes men look at you and be
like oh my God she's so hot like when
women want to be hot I get it but you
should only be hot for me you should
only want to be hot for me that's your
boy I think she can I wish you would
have showed that because it shows what a
child
what an insecure stupid [__] point
he's trying to make which is what I was
asking him about but you didn't show
that
he said he'd replay it he did not
they may have played it before but
he did not replay it when he said he
would so um is that normal behavior I
mean this is insecure man child behavior
my woman I know she wants to dress hot
but she can only dress hot when she's
with me okay that's his that's his
theory right
and then he goes on to say he feels
disgust
now this was the Baseline example that
means Sebastian agreed upon because
ho
[__] provocative whatever sexy
obviously varies from person to person
so I said okay take this picture of my
wife for an example as a Baseline and he
said yeah I agree I wouldn't want my
significant other just like that thank
you
okay so this this is what we're talking
about when he says disgust
here's the clip of me and Sebastian
agreeing on this Baseline okay that's
fair that's fair it's not no that's fair
if you have that understanding with your
partner I think that's totally fair but
this press it's not insecurity either
it's it's not insecurity it's just I
don't want I don't like that I don't
want it like let's follow the things
because you're you're basically no it's
not you're what you want would you want
your wife out there okay your wife out
there dress like a hoe
slam dunk on me which is what they say
they think this kid's got me oh
the definition of a hoe I guess is
I'm not quite sure what that means
but you just answer my question would
you would you want her out there
dressing or wearing as minimal clothing
as possible out in a club
what I want my well hold on
hold on no answer the question obviously
how could I don't know what he means by
ho clearly his idea of inappropriately
dressed is going to be a lot more
conservative than most people's so I
want to establish a baseline well let me
show you this yes okay well hold on does
my wife dressed like a hoe here because
I just want to get your she posted this
to someone would you go out to dinner
with your wife dressed like that of
course you wouldn't go like that I mean
why
I didn't say that we don't have
boundaries
I'm just using this Baseline okay you
know what I mean hold on okay
you good
all right Ethan okay so that's our
Baseline and then this is how
uh Babble reacts
to my wife
the amount not to my wife let's say but
the amount of clothes she's wearing
preference if you don't want to be with
a girl who's comfortable doing that
right but the but the underlying emotion
which was try I was trying to coax out
with Sebastian is that what is that
feeling of feeling off it's disgust
I think it's disgusting when someone
wants bro you are a [__] loser
I really don't know what to say it's
disgusting
this is Disco I'm disgusted that's the
feeling
go ahead go go on it's disgust
I think it's disgusting when someone
wants to be that trashy looking
does it
same way I think it's [__] disgusting
when I see dudes sag their pants and
have they boxers hanging out their ass
cheeks can I not be disgusted by
something you can be disgusted by
anything you want dude but it just I
mean you're just for [__] you're a
loser you know also sagging pants is not
the same as like showing a little
cleavage bro
right I'm disgusted
okay dude
so then they continue on uh to uh defend
our boy Sebastian the enlightened the
great Sebastian
um
here's here's where I think this is
interesting
would he be interested or Sebastian
love the idea of women policing how they
dress no tight fitting clothing no
watches no rings nothing the show is
status or wealth
not even nice shoes bro not even a nice
jacket you know why because you are
projecting into the world
that you have status that you have
wealth and obviously you're just doing
that to attract other women
why the [__] would you want to go out
and wear a nice watch it's disgusting
I'm literally repulsed by you wearing a
nice watch right now
I'll get it
my man must go outside wearing a full
hazmat suit or otherwise he's cheating
would you entertain that would you ever
argue that
and what's fun is that we totally expose
Sebastian in this moment for being a
total [__] hypocrite and they do not
show this they do not care about this
watch
this picture on Instagram yes dude this
is unacceptable
that's a third strap that like you're
well yeah that was that was before that
was before so 23 weeks how long you been
with your girlfriend about you and it
was also I mean
pretty inspiring I would say considering
I was women can't be inspiring with
their bodies pretty inspiring I mean
there's nothing inspiring by taking off
your shirt and showing men your tits
that's what you're doing you literally
just throw your shirt off
did they not think that this was
interesting relevant at all to the
conversation no no
it's also the single dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my life there's nothing
inspiring about showing your titties he
goes yeah look right there
so when girls do it it's so ugly you
know you did you did lose a lot of
weight since around the time of that
episode so I don't know maybe maybe this
maybe this photo this inspired you
oh my God you might be right it is
inspiring
but it's also disgusting
yeah yeah but the difference is is I
trained extremely hard what about the
girls who trained extremely hard and
then post like Gila is training right
now with a trainer yeah that's exactly
what Eli's photo was that she's showing
off okay I I didn't know that that's
great right oh well because every time a
girl posts a photo of her body it has to
be sexual it can't be that she's
achieved something he's so obviously
wrong and the way they go in and frame
this
again it's just pure bad faith right
yeah they straw man me something that I
don't even think and then they omit
Sebastian looking like a total [__]
hypocrite dumbass
it's super inspiring that she did that I
just want to be left alone I'm sorry bro
I know I'm sorry I'm just trying to work
through this and hopefully don't talk
about you anymore hold on hold on okay
you good all right Ethan all right cool
yeah see how silly it inspires me
actually don't you see how silly you're
being you go oh I didn't know that but
it's like put like everybody who's
posting pictures like there's a lot of
them just feel good they want to show it
off there's there's different contexts
right these things are a lot more
nuanced like if you're so again
impression or they are fresh fresh and
fit light diet
um Babylon reach
they agree with him uh and so my
question to them is are you okay with
women policing how you go out because
that conversation never happens
that conversation needs to happen
and I think the wearing the watch and
the nice shoes and all that [__] it's
the egg exact same thing you're trying
to you're trying to attract women with
that and I've seen the science on that
it's conclusive it's conclusive if you
believe in global warming yep yeah then
you must believe I I read you are trying
to cheat if you wear a nice watch
outside I wrote a study on it I said
men's tits are inspiring and women's are
sexual they're disgusting disgustingly
sexual
so again bad face
[__] losers a straw man you know get
up dude y'all are so lame again
if you want to talk at least engage with
what I really believe because this is
just
low hanging fruit [__] and I know
these guys post a lot they just want
content you know what I mean they're
desperate for content and that's what's
going on here
but at least be honest you know don't
act like high and mighty when you're
just straight up lying about what
happened [__] dumbasses
so uh moving on here they defending
Jordan Peterson yes friend of the show
we all know and love Jordan Peterson no
one of the
one of the Great Men of our time
LOL breaking down and crying and to them
this is just a beautiful moment a
courageous moment sex and it says a lot
about women
and and feminists and liberals or else
Jordan Peterson breaks down crying in
the internet cheers is the title of this
video Let's Take a Look people make
their mistakes as they stumble
Jordan's been a fascinating interview
thank you very much but it's so funny
that we live in a world where every
feminist and their girlfriends to talk
about men do this men need to show more
emotion dude starts crying about how sad
and lonely men are and women like you
[__] loser
see
okay okay
this is what I've always known to be
true since I was a young man all this
talk about feminists are four young men
out by the way they're showing like one
like random tweets I'm not even gonna
it's like what what are you trying to
catch I swear to God I swear they didn't
even show the likes on this one I mean
what the [__] why would you need men's
rights activists you guys are seeing it
right now hey I swear to God
wanting to be more vulnerable and sing
feelings
y'all y'all don't really want it no so
as someone that made fun of Jordan
Peterson this is not about men being
vulnerable this man is an unhinged
lunatic that's like the tenth time he's
cried today
he's not vulnerable he's unstable
and spewing
very dangerous ideology while he does it
and this is another thing that they're
doing they're making Jordan Peterson
very palatable whitewashing him he is
the most one of the most hateful
disgusting people on the whole [__]
internet he is just openly transphobic
he's like no yeah I don't like trans
people just straight the [__] up he is
that's like his whole thing he's with
the daily wire now and this whole
[__] thing is uh just transphobia
that's Auschwitz it's Auschwitz
and um he's he's also homophobic he
advocates for conversion therapy which
he called being against conversion
therapy is uh virtue signaling
apparently absolutely and so if you
isolate this one uh instance and say oh
all feminists all [__] libs are
weaponizing men being emotional
um is insane it's dishonest too because
you come on
come on you know Jordan Peterson's a
piece of [__] at least every budding
beauty or at least you know people
aren't making fun of him because he's
crying because he's vulnerable stop
being [__] obtuse
stop
ouchy I heard this man read a [__]
excerpt from Pinocchio and start crying
it's not vulnerable it's weird
just [__] weird man
I'd like to see what is he crying about
because I'm sure it's some weird dumb
[__] here let's watch
I want to ask you just quickly uh Olivia
Wilde there's a new movie out which she
says it's based on you this insane man
this pseudo-intellectual hero to the
in-cell community
Widow loner men uh who are you know
despicable in many ways
is that you are you the intellectual
hero to these people
sure why not you know
um people yes are you the intellectual
hero to these violent psychotic uh
school shooting misogynist yes
baby will start to cry
that's right
and I gave him the gun
I'll tell you what when my grandmother's
pubes brushed on my face
tears started running down my cheeks and
it occurred to me
men just want their grandmother to force
themselves upon them
is that too much to ask
no
and so I say women need to give it up
men you have a vagina men deserve no
they're entitled to sex for sexual kick
and women just keep they don't give it
up
YOLO [__] get some
hit me with the the audiobook
I dreamed I saw my maternal grandmother
sitting by the bank of a swimming pool
which was also a river
the genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair she was stroking herself
absent-mindedly
she walked over to me why didn't they
play a handful of pubic hair compacted
into something resembling a large artist
you should play this when you talk about
it my face
[Music]
several times to deflect her hand
finally unwilling or interfere with her
any further I let her have her way
that's all a man a boy wants
let his grandma insult him sexually
so yes I am their Heroes to come bring
it all together
after me for a long time by because I've
been speaking to disaffected young men
you know what a terrible thing to do
that is nobody's mad that you're
speaking to men it's what you're saying
quit speaking you
again it's all just intentionally obtuse
and why is he crying
pull your [__] together marginalization
you know if a woman started crying too
I'd just say pull your [__] together
not to do with
gender
we're supposed to have a voice oh but
they found three tweets of random
twitters with zero to one like of them
saying is he on estrogen or something uh
there was a fourth one that had 20 likes
making your money okay three or
something that's signed that's back by
sign
yeah that's settled but you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized yo they got that crying
cam on them yeah the way they got him
looking over his shoulder that was wild
that's stunning
a cut to the crying cam
you know Jordan beforehand he's like I
want you to set up a crying cam for me
I'm gonna cry about 20 minutes in so
here it is
God you know here it is here it is yeah
he's making sure
that was a good that was a good one how
demoralized people are
and certainly many young men are in that
category oh yeah you get these casual
insults these these in cells what does
that mean is it like these men they're
they don't know how to make themselves
attractive to women who are very picky
and good for them women like be picky
that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them you've been so controlled today
and yet in that brief moment you got
very emotional why
it's okay whatever so they make a whole
[__] big deal again
farming the views on this dumb [__]
[__] making Jordan Peterson look like a
victim of bullying imagine that
the dude who like
what is it he said about Elliot page
again that was like so obscenely [__]
violently transphobic I remember he said
Remember When Pride was a sin and it was
part of uh yeah pride is a sin gay pride
is a sin pride is not a virtue
oh
this this poor guy is being bullied
because that's a cardinal sin like pull
it together man
do your [__] research you're
embarrassing going out here
like this come on now remember when
Pride was a sin and Ellen Page just had
her breasts removed by a criminal
physician yeah
let's let's prop him up
he's a good guy and let's show him
some Grace when he starts crying you
know because all these feminists I tell
you what man feminists be be wild yeah
yeah you're one of them by the way I
know I need to shut up I'm one of them
okay but I don't know where Olivia is
she's the loser feminist researcher who
spends I'm starting to think that anyone
who's just not like an obedient kitchen
dweller is a feminist he's he throws
that as a quite a broad label make their
mistakes as they stumble uphill
Jordan's been a fascinating wait even
the creaking there in this and Morgan uh
Pierce's Studio what the hell interview
thank you very much what is so funny
that we live in a world where every
feminist and their girlfriends to talk
about men do this men need to show more
emotion dude starts like they say every
feminist and their girlfriend
every feminist and their girlfriends I
think girlfriends like they're friends
very much but it's so funny that we live
in a world where every feminist and
their girlfriends are talking about men
do this men need to show more emotion
dude starts crying about how sad and
lonely men are and women like you
[__] loser
see
okay okay
let's see these ones he pulled I don't
even care I mean these people don't that
one had that one had 300 telling people
that Jordan Pearson is helping you
become a man is possibly one of the most
embarrassing cell phones welcome I agree
yeah she's right that is also not about
crime nope so that was so or the quote
tweet right
or or calling him a [__] or a [__] or
whatever it is you're saying actually
it's a pretty general statement so I
don't see this supporting your uh your
claim this is what I've always known to
be true since I was a young man all this
talk about feminists are four young men
I could watch clips of Peterson crying
all day
not really a criticism I mean he does
there's got to be Jordan Peterson crying
compilation the dynamic Clips he he
cries readily yeah
not Jordan Peterson literally crying
over the plight of incels that's fair it
doesn't really support your your
argument that
people are calling him a [__] or
something
I swear to God I swear to God does
Jordan Pearson take estrogen I can't
imagine someone who purports to have so
much testosterone crying this often
scientifically this one maybe supports
their claim the only one I think they're
being ironic though for sure
scientifically does is fine
because they say scientifically
so what's the deal is this joke okay or
is it harming men [__] idiot dumbass
literally literally no consistency in
your arguments
but anyway so let's just say this one
you get it has no likes you even cut out
the engagement uh
uh intentionally why would you need
men's rights activists you guys are
seeing it right now because I swear to
God the only thing that's keeping me
going every day is the knowledge of
Jordan peers is going to put out another
strange video of him crying about a
weird verse in the Bible about how young
men are oppressed by blue jeans or
something
really that's supporting your thesis
that's a funny tweet that's just a joke
brother I don't know what's your problem
[__] you crying here about a joke loser
idiot
pathetic
wanting to be more vulnerable and seeing
feelings I swear to God I choose between
food water and videos Jordan if isn't
crying I'd probably start wow
wow some stuff man
too far
if he could find
but y'all y'all don't really want it no
y'all don't really want it Jordan crying
makes my day because time the time oh
whenever that happens [__] y'all
weaponize that [__]
yeah trusts
okay it's not not a man is crying it's
that an [__] is crying yeah right
yeah a Serial Sauber yeah
um oh yeah here's our here's our boy uh
sorry not beautiful no amount of
authoritarian tolerance is gonna change
that yeah dude sorry feminism has gone
too damn far
beautiful
[Laughter]
sorry beautiful I was like what the [__]
dude he's just a hateful [__]
misogynist he's your guy he's just very
weird
man
so the way they're framing this is like
laughably silly and by the way as I
don't weaponize men cry I think people
are touched when men cry
in general people find it endearing
mm-hmm
find do me show me a whole bunch of
examples
or even two examples of a man who's
having a genuine heartfelt moment crying
and it being used against you cried
relatively recently on this show and I
don't think I don't think I don't think
anybody uh Apple that against you
actually the only people did was a joke
about the chestnut song and that was too
far feminism went too far away I got it
the chestnuts I got a good one uh
Michael Jordan crying
and it became a meme
right that's true feminism went too far
with that one that was [__] up hey
dumbass and leech here's only some large
body of research that suggests a strong
relationship between misogynistic humor
and r word essay and crimes against
women hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on wait wait that does that's
impossible that totally country because
I believe in God I believe in climate
change right
so
this can't be the effects of sexist
humor and types of r word on men's
self-reported r word Pro proclivity and
victim blaming joking for gender
equality subversive humor against sexism
motivates Collective action in men and
women with weaker feminist identity
lights on at the end of the party are
Lads mags mainstreaming dangerous sexism
I mean I I don't know what this is
frankly yeah and I mean frankly there's
probably I mean there might be some
studies out there that find the opposite
I don't I mean I don't think I would be
a little bit surprised if there was
there's a study that said I don't know
jokes jokes are harmless jokes all jokes
be harmless the point is is that it was
being presented as if this
foreign
the Jordan crying thing
is that what you're talking about I hit
the button why
wait don't say it out loud I guess it uh
I don't think I needed to but you guys
were giving me crickets so I panicked
you didn't say anything on my computer I
was just saying I'll just say it again
just say it again because I don't I
don't think women are the just to be
serious for a while I don't think women
are the ones perpetuating like
specifically feminists are out here
being like look at weak ass Michael
Jordan it's like a sports meme yeah no I
know right no I know I know button
you guys
gave me Chris because we didn't react I
mean
that's what I expect thank you all right
so good so good that's what I expect
from my uh friendly neighborhood
feminist loser yep
all right can you uh do you guys hear
that
we gotta get the floor fixed in here I
don't know what's going on yeah that was
um
that was the most unneeded Panic so far
okay I've never had to do it
nothing bad
I had to do it yeah and and and Frank to
go back to what you were saying yes I I
agree and it's interesting that
um
yeah I I do think that the societal
pressure to be a man and toughen up and
not cry is definitely coming from other
men primarily I I don't know why they
have this argument that like women don't
actually want vulnerable men I find
that's just really weird and un it's not
really reflected in the real world
um what do you mean emotional like
unhinged or do you mean like someone
who's comfortable talking about how they
feel about this right that's that that's
I think an important distinction to make
I I women I don't think want emotionally
unstable men right and I don't think
that's feminism emotionally unstable
women either I think that's kind of a
universal right human thing I thought
this comment was pretty good I've been
preacher no better than Peterson at
times they give young men the tools and
vocabulary to process current events but
behind their friendly demeanor they are
rarely ever sympathetic to women or
lgbtq their platform and content are all
geared towards men like Peterson's
audience who struggle to find validity
in any non-male-centered cause their
central theme of modern women bad can be
seen through their Channel they just
Pander to male loneliness while subtly
implanting Centrist takes about sjws
yeah that's pretty spot on
all right so now we've kind of set the
atmosphere so let's get into responding
directly uh to to their recent video
so
me and Hassan talked about them briefly
on
last Thursday but by the way just before
we get into this quick aside I I'm
seeing in the chat again people are
having their YouTube's having like
serious problems today oh no
the app is like non-stop uh yeah
crashing for people for me it seems like
it's fine on desktop I've seen lots of
people say I'm watching on desktop no
problem there seems to be a problem with
the uh mobile app let me open and see
I'm just curious if I could pull up the
live
yeah it's working fine on my phone
uh it what's interesting is it keeps
seeming to happen in waves like we are
coming in ways coming in waves I beat
you Zach you [__] quick
uh funny stuff all right so let's let's
let's keep it going because I wasn't
kidding when I said I have a lot to get
to
like a lot
we're almost done though right no
we still have for two hours we're not
almost done oh God look at the document
bro we go hard in the paint all right
listen listen like I said uh
uh uh Babble and reach uh season is open
if I'm gonna talk about it I'm just
going to talk about it crying Jordan the
other crying I'll try to I'll try to
pick up the pace though there's a
[__] lot left all right there's more
left let's go I've got places to beat we
could do a two-parter I guess
foreign
how long how many minutes did we say
that they've made videos about us
145 145 minutes well it doesn't matter
now because okay we're striking back
yeah 120. so you have 25 minutes no no
to be on par with them no I get to
respond I get doubled the time because I
have to regret no because I have to
watch their content that's not the
sacred rules of debate okay right no no
no no no all right no no no no no no no
no no
they do they poke the bear we get to go
Revenant on their ass okay no but listen
it's fair they did 145 mm-hmm so I get
290. Leonardo DiCaprio right two nine I
get 290.
how long is 290 tomorrow's show at some
point all right I mean no that's five
hours we could do five hours today still
Pro you see
easy baby
all right let's let's try to move on
though
hey can you please not make fun of
Jordan uh Ian please feminism has done
enough to that poor man what is the
origin of that image could you put that
back up for a second
[Laughter]
that's a straight stock photo of him of
a man going through it
all right so let's get so yeah me and
Hassan talked briefly about them on
Thursday I was venting a little bit
pieces of [__] they are and of course as
they usually do they made a 26 minute
video about like us talking about them
for a brief amount of time called
Ethan kleinesson threatened us with war
and go on an unhinged rant so let's just
I'm gonna react to this video now now
I'm sorry y'all guys get in front of the
camera and talk like your his definition
of unhinged is just saying that trans
women don't belong in women's sports
whoa points and don't make me roll that
[__] video again brother
they're always constantly trying to
downplay their transphob like
blatantransphobia hey hey hey whoa oh I
said I said I said a dude who just who
just transitioned this morning shouldn't
be able to compete against women
don't make me roll it
don't make me [__] roll it bro
I'm rolling it
I've been banned from
yeah
[Music]
you did more than that be honest
transolate you did more than that dude
don't be a coward now ain't nobody
trying to talk about y'all that deeply
oh I never really dissected this but I
loved this moment where he's like y'all
nobody really cares about y'all okay
anyway but everyone's talking about you
but like it's all your own fault okay
listen when they're talking about you
the reason why folks talk about y'all is
because you guys put yourselves out
there all the time and then constantly
demand and change from everybody
[Music]
I think that I've proven with scientific
certainty
that
they've done more than just say trans
people shouldn't compete in sports thank
you I rest my case also global global
climate change is real science is gay
size is gay also whatever that means
um
I accidentally closed the document
give me one sec here guys
I got you record scratch moment I sent
in Discord I I got it I'm just trying to
Okay so
let's keep it going then
all of that aside
just as a Nick peach and cream because
they're soft bro they're like a nice
thank you Hassan
okay I think I think it demasculates
them and that's why I like it
[Music]
okay so here we go okay
hold on what was that response I think I
think it demasculates them and that's
why I like it
[Music]
yo they said action and then he did that
there's something they're such phonies
that that dude literally said action and
then goes
but anyway listen
listen listen
they're right I'm actually going to eat
crow on that one it was it's not a good
name and after doing a little bit of
research they do seem comfortable in
their masculinity so I assumed that
there were like other red pill guys who
are like deeply deeply insecure in their
masculinity and are always trying to you
know act Macho and stuff over
compensating but I was totally wrong
about them so I might agree with
everybody that peaches and cream not a
good name and I'll even take it a step
further I didn't know that fresh and fit
called them apples and peaches and that
just makes me embarrassed and ashamed of
myself cringe like they they changed
their channel icon
to peaches and cream that's how not
offended they were
and that's fair it wasn't a good it
wasn't a good Ethan W Dan peaches and
crazy sounds sexy it reminds me of that
B2K song that's what it always makes me
think of too so so I'm I'm I'm taking
back I'm officially taking back the
peaches and cream moniker it's rewind
time and we are officially endorsing
Babble and reach thank you yes
so you guys you guys definitely got me
on that one but
what's super interesting
is they go on
and they totally lose me and see if you
guys can spot what I'm talking about
even Abba's kind of like chill dude I I
don't want these guys to be mad it's a
112 songs
hold on it's funny how [__] here
now what now listen carefully
to our boy reach who in his namesake but
he's reaching straight into some doo-doo
straight into a flaming bag of dude
first one to be oh you know what they do
they die lgbtq mumbo jumbo whatever the
[__] and then hold the [__] phone
when did I let him cook okay let him let
him cook let him cook the first chance
you get to weaponize that [__] you do
it there you go Ethan I'm soft okay you
a [__]
and you instrumentalize all that [__]
that's what you do oh no games this gave
that equality all that good stuff but
the minute you want to weaponize this
and I'm gonna tell you all the people
from the lgbtq community just noticed
this [__] from people that say that
they're allies to you okay watch how
they move to insult
that's being you are you done is he an
insult for them well you got a bunch of
people on your side
um and they're like yeah
can we could someone cut him off because
uh preach maybe someone should agree
this is a button moment
are you thinking what you are bro when
did I say anything about gay people
nobody called you gay this is the
biggest [__] self-report possibly of
all time I said that they're soft and I
wanted to demasculate them and he
interpreted that as me calling him gay
you okay and went on an entire tirade
about how I secretly hate gay people but
why is it that you think that being gay
is synonymous with soft
and
unmasculine can you explain that to me
because I don't see any way to interpret
this and by the way they both
were there edited it and kept this in
they thought he thought he was doing
something here explain to me how this
isn't like the craziest most homophobic
rant I've ever seen how the [__] did you
just
how did you just do that uh one more
time
you get to weaponize that [__]
thank you Hassan
okay I think I think it demasculates
them and that's why I like it and
[Music]
these guys are so masculine it gets on
my nerves you need to be demasculated so
peaches and Community I I don't want
these guys to be masculine he's doing
the gay voice that you got canceled for
by the way I think I didn't do that
don't say that okay well okay you're
rich Lux if you're watching here's your
man here's your real man right here he's
doing the gay voice you get his dad yes
I was waiting for that damn Rich jealous
of me Dan is jealous of me Rich if
you're watching get us a sound drop if
you're saying I can't stand Babylon
reached and we'll play that on the show
and Dan ruined my whole Disney trip
I love him for that to be honest
jealous of me
[Music]
[Applause]
can't be masculine right that's
literally what he's saying he's equating
he's equating masculinity with
you've ever seen any of these Bears bro
they'll cut they'll break you in half
brother I've seen me you know what I
mean what the [__] and soft all gay men
are emasculate and soft they straight up
just said that
also just can I draw attention to the
irony of him wearing a Rage Against the
Machine shirt while he's going off on
this homophobic rant a explicitly
leftist like communist
rock group like what why are you wearing
that they they would not like you I'm
curious what Tomorrow
there's so much irony kicked into the
scene yeah he goes on about Ethan
pretends to support you but he hates you
and he'll use you against someone at at
the strop of a hat it's like when the
[__] did I say anything about gay bro
that's what you're doing right now the
irony is like it's it's palpable
hold on it's funny how [__] and
they left this in the first one to be oh
you know what gave this date that lgbtq
mumbo jumbo whatever the [__] and then
the first chance no he goes he goes
nobody really honestly cares about this
stuff hmm he's what he's saying trust me
nobody actually genuinely cares about
the lgbtq he's only tokening you and
this is proof what I've always known
nobody cares about this [__] you get to
weaponize that [__] you do it there you
go Ethan I'm sorry
I'll be a [__] but you're a [__] you
are just like coconuts and Barbados
right now brother you thought who are
you talking to
I know you're not talking to me
I mean this really
this really just sums up the whole kind
of thesis of this is that they they love
they love to make something up and then
get mad about it is there the straw man
yeah like that that's the classic move
is a hundred percent something that
didn't happen and then and then go on a
rant about it and then to their fans it
seems reasonable because they're like oh
if he did say that then that's then yeah
but uh penetration actually I didn't
mention anything about Gabe I mean have
you seen hunger FF that guy's masculine
[__] he takes hands like elbow deep up
his ass
yeah I'm just saying
that man's got a prolapse the size of a
goddamn Mount Everest
he's got the Mount Everest of prolapses
yeah King he is a king yeah but uh wow
this is amazing this is this is really
amazing stuff uh it's incredible is he
wearing a holster by the way what's
going on there I've been wondering that
the whole time
Crowder moment it's hard to tell if it's
a holster I don't want to put that on
him because
I'd be surprised if he was but I don't
know what else what are those are
extenders
uh no suspenders shouldn't go under I
think he's in Canada you can't it's not
this you can't really nobody carries
loosey-goosey with oh they are
I don't I I can't tell if it's uh what
it is also I just want to say he does
seem very sensitive to being called Gay
I didn't say that and you just got like
way sent off brother
these little strappies make him feel
masculine his little strappy I mean
that's why Crowder doesn't it maybe he
doesn't need he
when I do my strappies real tight it
makes my biceps look big
you guys hear that
we have got to get that checked out
so we went to the audience and sure
crazy
and before you all try to be like oh
they're classing me bro y'all are
millionaires stop fix your floor you got
no excuse
you just suck at making videos we see
your reviews stop it stop it
all that [__] that's what you need
equality all that good he's doing
something a minute you want to weaponize
it right now and I'm straight up cooking
from people that say that their allies
to you okay watch how they move to
insult other month that's who are you
talking to is
for them
they're like yeah what's wrong this man
just built like the whole Lord of the
Rings Multiverse
from me saying he's soft
you probably take an Indiana what they
think
uh there's only um one Canon Universe in
The Lord of the things okay I'm sorry
yeah sorry I'll back it up legendarium
this man just went from soft to you take
it in the ass
dude chill bro chill
preach or Abba you better step in on
your man dude you got no chill
what you are
you are
homie's just on his phone he's like bro
I I don't care
they they react to the videos on the
phone to be fair to him nah he's fair
housing Twitter he's like whatever here
he goes again yeah here he goes reach is
reaching that's not a night eye let's
just also appreciate their way to insult
us is to make us sound more feminine
no never said anything about feminine
I said demasculate
so do you see how ignorant
you are
demasculate doesn't mean feminine
I I have to say something
demasculate isn't a word does it start
with an emasculation
because you said in the original video
it's emasculate thank you okay thank you
okay I've been fighting I'm [__] not
paying you to correct me
loser
[Music]
I'm trying to follow their advice and
not surround myself with
I guess you would be following their
advice okay whatever
oh yeah feminine so it solves so it's
bad that's you I don't even care dude I
don't care but that's you that's what
you do I don't care I just gonna rant
about it for three minutes about some
transphobic misogynistics freak [__] I
don't care
I just called you soft
and here you are
fully triggered
we don't care I know I know I know I
believe you I believe them they don't
care I believe them
that you guys don't care
absolutely I think it's funny when
someone says like you know people it's
funny because the red pillars do the
same thing yay that's this is my
favorite they you are red pillar you are
a red pillar they this is part of the
book this is their stick they're like no
no no no we're above all that no you
guys are red pillars
make you sound more feminine oh that's
feminine energy you do the exact same
thing this is why we tell you A lot of
these feminism red pillars are two sides
of this and again they just Associated
feminine
with being soft
or it seems to think weak weak and soft
is a feminine feature to them because I
never met I never said feminine
so I'm not sure where this is all coming
from same coin when it comes down to it
they get upset they use the exact same
language notice we never said okay since
a feminine type of dude no I didn't say
that about you easy could have done that
you don't because I don't lose anything
wrong if you're a feminine man this is
like the straw man of all Spider-Man I
you know what the [__] are you talking
who are you talking to man go ahead live
your best life but for these guys that's
actually a bad thing so no matter how
much they trade any of these virtues
when it comes down to it when they got
to get dirty they use the exact same
ammunition exactly are you done now okay
you should have erased that whole part
why did you keep that in
and then of course this is like the
classic tactic of Ethan said something
offensive about gay people once
therefore all of his opinions are
invalid uh again I didn't even mention
gay anything gay at all which makes me
again wonder why this is here but I'll
play it because
um
what is this oh I see sorry I lost my
spot again in the dock
um
so I don't I I'm I'm not afraid to
confront my my wrongs
quote controversies you know re-watching
this clip is it's very embarrassing it's
very dumb it's very offensive and I
don't know why I was I why I I can't
imagine why I did that and it is coming
from a homophobic place and I I greatly
regret it and I'm actually happy to talk
about it as often
as I need to right to to make that clear
so after not mentioning anything gay
they're apparently trying to prove that
I'm homophobic times I think I think one
that comes to mind Jordan Peterson that
you described as probably being someone
that would be a bottom that's the only
one I can think of off the top of my
head but like I've I've heard I'm just
showing this in the interest of like
being fair okay I did this sometimes
made me say like oh this is the one that
might be being transparent you can't
always tell like who's the top who's the
best do you find it offensive if I say
by being like oh he's a he's probably a
bottom is that the problem
absolutely it's offensive um because the
gay men already you have to you have to
deal with certain assumptions about
femininity and masculinity I mean it is
funny though I just that's all I'm
asking for it just feel a little more
conscious of it so would you consider
yourself a top or bottom or you don't do
that the labels and I mean this was all
peace and love and with the respect
Ethan it's none of your business but you
have a preference one way or the other
but that's another dangerous assumption
too can I guess don't you tell me if
it's right if I guess right it's
embarrassing doesn't mean you're like
our beta you could be Alpha and also
still be on the bottom uh but but if you
were does it does the poop pass like any
differently from before is it all normal
functions like I get it doesn't leak out
but I wonder if it just comes out a
little the labels okay so anyway
embarrassing I don't like watching it
but there it is just being fair now back
to them why did they show this it's got
nothing to do with anything and this is
what they're trying to prove well prove
a point of something I never said right
that's they're the straw man yes right
look going on for five minutes about
talking about something I never [__]
said
foreign
but
um yeah this is this is a tactic where
people go look at this thing that
Ethan's apologized for and talked ad
nasium about and learn and hopefully
learned and grown from uh but here
here's something bad he did therefore
opinions uh invalid about anything
forever nice
just understand like I said I don't
really care that you call it peaches and
cream apples and Peach whatever the
reason you do it I think nicknames like
that are funny you guys constantly
police other people's language talk
about this is transphobic bro you gotta
chill out literally called you soft
not that serious okay so uh then he goes
on to say
uh that the uh internet beef thing is
cringy hmm that's interesting breath
have you heard yourself thing about Abba
and preach that they don't know about me
they they haven't uh they don't bother
me enough yet but I'll tell you this
I'm [__] insane
and if you and if you want to if you
want to do the war thing that's my
favorite thing in the world but I'm
close they're they're just they're
they're pathetic they're Liars they're
dishonest and they're phonies
they're not even genuine that's the
thing right here look at this so I I
hope that I'm proving that statement
but I will admit again I got a little
carried away I I agree it's a little
cringy the way I was talking about it I
get you know I get into this whole this
war thing is kind of a meme on the
channel and
the whole crazy Ethan Goblin mode
Ethan's kind of a meme but I'll agree
that it's a cringy the way I talked
about it for sure but the way that these
guys try to act now that they're not
like T Kings you guys are the Brewers
themselves your whole Channel even more
than me people call me drama you are a
straight up gossip Channel my dudes
that's what you do I like how it sounds
quiet like man I don't want to be
involved in this nonsense it's not like
fuel I'm gonna be honest with you guys
this whole like internet War beef is the
most corny [__] doesn't want to be
involved because anytime he mentions you
even the slightest bit passing you cut
20 videos about them because you're
[__] T Kings
you guys are Master Brewers
you know what I mean
so let's do a tea ceremony [__]
together me and you let's just be real
about who we are again this is the him
acting like he's above it like he's
better look at their channel it's all T
Brothers
[__] plan chill
just kidding
Ian just uh sneezed
the first time I heard a uh sound from
me in all all episodes like I know
sometimes he's been like covering people
multiple times and be like oh there's a
beef we just cover it because it's
relevant and people want to see it
people think going back and forth is
just a war like I don't know to me
that's just a cringy language like
people use the most violent like oh I
got bear smoke for them intellectually
like kill yourself again like I didn't
say that I don't consider myself an
intellectual at any capacity actually
kill yourself
that the classic kill yourself line
where he blurs the kill because he's a
giant [__] [__] he won't even own
what he says coward just say you got a
rebuttal and just you're just using
words I have a rebuttal is that what you
guys do
excuse me I have a rebuttaling thing
again is that what you're doing in this
video you dumb [__] hypocrite coward
so stupid this is stupid it sounds like
Crowder intellectuals be like we're
gonna verbally joust in an intellectual
Warfare like shut the [__] up how old
yeah I didn't say there are no
intellectuals involved in any of this I
guarantee our side or yours I guarantee
I'm not intellectual nor have I ever
claimed anything stupid that's the last
thing anyone should consider meeting
YouTubers beefing that's all this is
what are you what is this what is this
feels like a manga for like YouTubers
it's Digimon no there's like a whole
showing it like this it's just it's war
is serious this internet is not yeah
I don't know what that means they just
say anything
I don't think they I think they just say
anything
again this is the guy who says this
whole internet beef is cringy I have not
done a proper video about them 15 15.
right 15.
you're the T King Brothers just just
you're a gossip
Nails emojis you know what I mean let's
talk shop
change your name to AB Abba and T I
don't know oh my God this is the tea
seriously this is stop it you're not
better you're you do more drama than
anyone on the internet practically
good
at least I own it I love the gossip I
love it
you know what it is but now they go uh I
thought this next part is really
interesting I have a good life nobody
cares in real life nobody gives a [__]
about any of us people go out to their
jobs none of this matters so just calm
down with the whole War I mean look yeah
so
this thesis of his I go outside nobody
cares jokes are jokes and science
um again this man has made 30 plus
videos on trans people and he's going to
sit there and say nobody cares everybody
goes outside and nothing matters uh well
dude that's a nice privileged take for
you to say it doesn't affect me I don't
care but meanwhile trans hate crimes and
suicide rates are way way way up in
recent history but guess what it's trans
people's fault according to them trans
people are over four times more likely
than cisgender people to be victims of
violent crimes according to UCLA School
of Law
transgender hate crime statistics from
the FBI show a 587 percent increase
between 2013 and 2019. increases are
also seen in data collected by non-law
enforcement agencies as well with the
Human Rights Campaign noting a record 44
transgender people killed in 2020. in
2021 that number Rose to 50. I'm so glad
for you that you go outside and none of
this matters and it's all good because
jokes are jokes it's science
it's just science
and then I keep going back he says it's
transgender it's people's fault though
there they need the trans activists are
doing this to themselves you know if you
weren't so visible if you weren't always
talking and like trying to defend your
right to exist
and maybe people won't shut up thank you
so much it's like just shut up dude
according to National Library of
Medicine the suicide rates attempt among
trans people this should concern
everybody 50 up to 50 across countries
you think that's [__] funny you think
that's like cool that you just keep
making trans people like the punching
bag the butt of all your [__] jokes
30 videos bro you think that that
doesn't have an effect on the millions
of [__] like conservative uh
aggrieved men who watch your videos you
don't think
it affects them at all while 50 percent
up to 50 of transgender people attempt
suicide
that's nice for you that you walk
outside and it doesn't matter nobody
cares
like [__] you guys I know it's all jokes
and stuff and being silly and just
showing what idiots are but this is real
[__] you're doing
y'all just want views and clicks but
trans people are the butt of your jokes
and 50 of them up to try to kill
themselves
that's [__] pretty funny dude
and yes I believe in global warming
whatever that has to do with anything
that's not just in the U.S UK also
reports crimes against transgender
people saw the biggest rise ever
the previous year
4 355 reports 56 up also he told me to
kill myself so clearly he doesn't take
it seriously at all this man told me to
kill myself he bleeped the kill because
he's a [__] bitch-ass coward loser
that won't even say anything with his
chest because he's a [__] coward told
me to kill myself why
uh because you were cringy because I was
cringy yeah
like trans people to be fair you were a
little cringy so all right I guess I
know what I got in maybe he has a point
I I don't know I don't know
yep pretty cool dude
cool guy
who's gonna try to say that he wasn't
talking to me when he said kill himself
but like whatever bro kill yourself I
don't care he's I mean I don't know how
else I'm supposed to take it
it was clearly implied yeah he's talking
to me he's talking about me he's talking
to me
cool
keep keep putting that out there bud
you're awesome
okay so now these guys have this whole
thing
about they're the great Hassan Defenders
they keep bringing this up we defended
Hassan why doesn't he thank us why don't
they mention it so I'm bringing this up
just to show them I don't [__] care
I'm not ignoring it you guys are such
losers watch this part of this is that
like a lot of the people that they
feature in their commentary are
oh people that like hold on don't get
roasted here
if you play Hogwarts Legacy no no
scroll down looking for any video about
Hassan so I could click it and watch it
like a lot of the people I'd only I
still don't even see the video they're
talking about where apparently
I don't see it are oh yeah this is the
first one I saw and I clicked it the
people that they feature back up the
video just a little bit more so we go
yeah
part of this is that like a lot of the
people that they feature where is it in
their commentary are uh-oh people that
like hold on don't you get one where is
it here the first one does it even is it
even on the screen again what are you
I'm really trying to give them the
benefits of doubt I'm looking carefully
but I'm not seeing any other one that we
skip again I'll watch it again you guys
because they go do a whole big thing
about I'm a whole [__] for ignoring it
part of this is that do you guys [__]
right at the very beginning there's a
top row okay okay let's try that here
I'm gonna go frame by frame for you guys
yeah let's go frame by frame for you
guys
because you watch you watch it just
thumbnails okay okay right at the
beginning
I don't see it there okay frame by frame
for you guys this is all for you guys
because I'm a whole ass [__] for
skipping it
I don't see it still don't see it
still don't see it yeah I think we can
put that to bed I I'm not seeing a video
about Hassan
uh chat editions we're like missing
something obvious please tell us but
apparently I'm a whole ass [__] she's
he's saying it's so confident so now
listen to them I'm doubting myself this
is what they do they just present stuff
as this as if it happened but like what
the [__] are you talking about here
watch oh people that like hold on don't
you get roasted here
if you play Hogwarts Legacy wait you
pass on the other one that we were ah
you were [__] you thought that right
you're a [__]
like what what other ones what is he
talking they made a video defending
Hassan against a false accusation
they're accusing me of scrolling past it
but in the video
it's not there
it's just not there
so again they just I'm just going to
start doing that like
[Music]
fourth top row
this is Andrew that's the very big back
up again there isn't like a row that we
already passed I don't think so and
you're trying to
yeah
this is the this is where it starts on
the top right it says Andrew Tate
terminal lung cancer
okay part of this is that like a fourth
bit everybody keeps saying fourth video
top row I think you well if you're going
to uh
General and you click their latest
videos the one that they did about
Hassan and Ethan on leftovers is top
right though so I know I think everybody
thinks that the video defending Hassan
is six months old where you're at on
their page right now is two months ago
thank you there's it wasn't on the page
[Applause]
that looks like Hassan in the top right
but it's it's not what they're taking
it's not on the screen I don't know what
to say
just not here
somebody said oh my bad bro okay okay so
maybe so here they are again
making [__] up and going on this whole
[__] tirade about how much of a [__]
I am you guys are [__] you guys are
[__] liars and I'm gonna start just
making [__] up about y'all yo I saw
fresh and I saw a Babylon reach in a
coffee shop and they were just spitting
on trans people bro
I saw it on YouTube
and so now I'm gonna go on a 20-minute
tour raid about how they spit on trans
people all these people are apologizing
to Hassan in our chat now for confusing
him with Andrew Tate yeah I mean I
thought so first when I looked but like
so maybe you got confused by that so now
that we have resolved that it's not on
the screen okay let's watch their
reaction okay like a lot of the people
that they feature in their commentary
are oh people that like hold on don't
get roasted here
if you play Hogwarts Legacy wait you
pass on the other one that we were uh
you were [__] you thought that right
you're a [__] do they lie do they just
lie like nothing there's no maybe they
got confused by it too I don't know
because apparently a lot of people
thought that was the sun thumbnail so
I'm being charitable to them maybe he
saw that and also thought that was I
would expect them to know their own
channel better yeah right but I don't
think they think much about the content
they make okay
but if you're gonna go on this confident
of a of a rant I mean be right at least
when we defend the dude that's next to
you
you've been right to the other wow you a
[__] you uh yeah that didn't happen it
actually didn't happen so who's the
[__] actually who's the [__] reach hey
can I hear what's going on inside his
head right now
understandable
yeah this is his thought process when
accusing me of being a whole [__] yeah
that's what I'm feeling yo it's actually
insane how disingenuous this man is okay
so you guys are gonna walk this all back
right
surely you guys are going to apologize
and walk this all back until and now you
need to call me genuine
you need to call me the most genuine
[__] you've ever met
it is actually actually it's actually
frightening how it disingenuous you
Liars are we literally see him scrolling
and he's lying it is crazy and you
calling us a liar yeah
also what did you like even if that
video was there what did you lie about
what I'm what is the lie that they're
referring to they're saying I don't know
I don't know I don't know it's confusing
right like but I'm calling you guys a
liar yes and thank you for proving my
point I'm scrolling as he's lying it is
crazy and you calling us a liar you're
lying right now
bruh don't you see how [__] silly you
look right now creeks
this is delusional Babylon creeks
[Music]
yeah you a [__] like oh I got
that's crazy are you done
wait it is it is a holster isn't it now
he's lifting his arms wait he's wearing
a holsters hold up you better stop that
silly [__] right now brother
oh no it's a phone case this is It's a
phone holster that's work bro that's
work what listen you can wear whatever
you want you can wear whatever he wants
well except that rage against oh it's
Sage Against the Machine oh interesting
look it's not actually Rage Against the
Machine Sage against all right we're
gonna issue a retraction right now you
can wear that they'd Hammer you hard on
that they will Hammer us super hard yeah
so are you guys done with this uh lie
unless you are right okay okay dude so
they're obsessed with this notion that
they defended Hassan
um here's the context on this Hassan
allegation before we continue Philly D
covered it and they showed this too so
we're all on the same page here so let's
watch this
or as any of the specifics here it all
appears to start with a Discord message
from a streamer by the name of lavaloon
back in September what they're saying
there I think Hassan's outraged about
everything is really funny because he
slept with my friend when she was 17 and
he was 24. with a streamer by the name
of Judd logic featuring this message in
a stream yesterday in the clip showing
the message gets around and as of
recording it has over 160 000 views now
with this many were pretty skeptical
about the applications because lavaloon
apparently is fought with streamers in
the past and then as it started gaining
traction she changed some of the details
in her story saying in a sense delete a
tweet that the relationship between
Hassan and her friend was legal and
saying that her comment was about Hassan
allegedly partaking in an adult
relationship with a woman five years as
Junior they're going on to say on
patreon Hassan [__] slept with my very
young friend when he was not so young it
was legal but he's denounced men
publicly for doing much less I don't
care about it and she's never going to
come forward but the fact exists
nonetheless an example of hypocrisy and
adding let me be clear she's not coming
forward because she doesn't care because
none of this was a big deal it was legal
I barely cared asan did nothing illegal
probably nothing immoral either and so
unsurprisingly all of this makes its way
back to Hassan and he responds to the
allegations in a stream and there saying
the woman question was 19 at the time of
their relationship such a ridiculous
slanderous lie this person
makes it I think he was 24 at the time
or something too so on its face in the
reporting it's being debunked okay
that we both saw the same video so now
they expect Hassan to get on his [__]
knees and kiss the ground they walk on
because
watch this
he's not I don't know you know what
kills me they're accusing me of
scrolling past that video right ignoring
that I guess they defended Hassan yeah
which is I guess hypocritical because I
criticized them for defending fresh and
fit that's their Theory
I see okay I just passed through the
original video leftovers again and I I
don't see it anywhere
that was a good idea
you jumped scrolled for a second that's
fantastic I mean it's just it's the
irony is just fantastic you're a liar
bro
you called us a liar
I'm gonna tell a lie about you
to prove you wrong
he was like yo it's so crazy they defend
no we just defended was you making up at
false accusations or having Brown
someone come on who made false
accusation and was easily proven to be a
liar okay that's what we talked about
the same way when the Buddy's sitting
right across of you Hassan was accused
by somebody else even though we don't
like him as an individual we still
defend itself because on principle the
person who was because on principle we
always
defend the men yeah another way to look
at it that's our that's basically our
guiding North flexible yeah yeah as long
against him was out here and I hope that
Hassan actually says something about
that because when he was accused he
didn't mind when other people went after
that girl and said yo she's lying but
then when especially fit all of a sudden
we're evil people for doing the exact
same behavior it's a bit bizarre it is
it is a bit bizarre that you make that
point
so so uh do you find it odd that like
it's almost like they're motivated like
they made first of all they covered this
story for Content let's not [__]
pretend like you did this altruistically
in the video you watched Philly D
debunked the whole [__] story okay
nobody cares that you defended him he
didn't ask you to defend it in fact I'm
pretty sure he'd be happy if you didn't
talk about it because you're just signal
boosting a bogus story okay so why is it
that you think he needs to thank you
is that why you did it
so that he'll thank you
uh
what is this Behavior you know what I
mean as what the [__] you owe me a debt
of gratitude my friend for talking about
this non-story
it's weird
all of a sudden he didn't mind when
other people son actually said something
about because when he was accused of
something he didn't mind when other
people went after that girl and said yo
she's lying
yeah
okay dude
[__] weirdos
yeah their default position is just
women be lying I mean to be real so not
that surprising
so then uh they go on
and they say the Fret fresh and fit
accuser which we'll get into soon and
the Hassan accuser is the same behavior
which was out here let's let's take this
out and I hope the Hassan actually says
something about that because when he was
accused of something he didn't mind when
other people went after that girl and
said yo she's lying but then when it's
fresh to fit all of a sudden we're evil
people for doing the exact same behavior
is a bit bizarre but anyways like I said
y'all live your best lives like I said
so the girl who accused his son which
was basically not even a first-hand
account she said
I have a friend who slept with him when
she was underage but she doesn't want to
say anything versus a girl's first-hand
account of this experience she had with
fit
that was vetted beforehand is the same I
mean this is very telling about how he
views women accusers it is it's very
telling but one also would be a crime
one is a crime sleeping with a marriage
girl and the other one just called in to
share a bad date yeah no but both are
going against men so both are bad I do
think that there's something interesting
going on here I mean not they not all
accusations are created equal right but
they want it to be that way because it's
easier to dismiss because the real one
it's way easier to women talk about and
dismiss them if they're not thinking
about the victims themselves as people
like all of these people are gonna go
and harass this woman who's already
dealing with something so personal and
so hurtful versus this girl
made something up about a friend of hers
like even it doesn't equal it doesn't
it's not a firsthand account no and it's
a crime so again it's nice that they
have this tendency to be like women be
lying essentially
um
and so now we're going to get into their
their defense of fresh and fit okay and
we are we're actually I see the end in
distance here Dan so don't panic good
because apparently I just I've just
learned that DeSantis just had his
Twitter space with Elon Musk
it's like been a disaster has it been
yeah he could have been watching it live
or listening live what happens when two
charismatic juggernauts meet two black
holes of Charisma there's just so much
merge the black holes have merged Hassan
has been watching for the past two hours
oh man over and over crashing we're just
gonna have a lot of things to say about
it it's so sad so anyway let's let's
so here's just a little bonus clip
before we get into that I thought you
guys would like this
um
he says that not he's implying that uh
I'll play it let me take a step further
she'd reported another dude before these
two right and everybody celebrated her
go Queen you're so brave she told us the
details of the story you know what
happened this is what you claimed happy
she said she went on this date with this
dude they were flirting they went back
to his place and then I and then I made
a and then I I made like a joke about it
my first video was like LOL that one
time when like uh this like La comedian
like kind of forced me to eat his ass
when I was like pushing against him lol
um and it was just like a funny video
when the way you made it sounded so
funny that sounds really extreme and
this might be a bit [__] up but like I
feel like eating ass has got to be one
of the hardest things to force someone
to do a lot oh my god there was a lot of
pressure on my head and he was like
keeping my mouth full and making sure
that he was not making eye contact with
me so I couldn't say no like it was very
weird I wouldn't say that to me but it
was definitely like a very strange
situation and basically she was eating
them from the back and then she went
home so his thesis is that he knew she
was lying when she said
he forced me to eat his ass
right and it's just giving me very much
giving me keemstar like just close your
mouth
well like I feel the logic is infallible
I need to do a dromler today on the Jake
Paul sexual assault allegations or just
play the sound but I don't watch this
whole [__] video you got to just
close your mouth
do we have and quite frankly is there
really no way to just close your mouth
just close your mouth close your mouth
it's it's a simple it's absolutely
irrefutable logic there but like I feel
like eating ass has got to be one of the
hardest things to force someone to do
yep therefore she's lying
she was lying to be fair that girl but
the logic is uh fantastic
so let's move on okay so this girl who
called into our show
uh was the
was the subject of
really extreme ridicule by them and
fresh and fit
now just as an important atmospheric
here is ABBA talking about
was on the receiving end of a false
allegation when he was in the Army and I
do think this is important atmospheric
like when I first joined they said don't
get involved female service members it's
very risky I took that [__] to heart and
I had an incident where I never even
came in contact with somebody never
physically close to them and they try to
make some story up thankfully
there were multiple eyewitnesses that I
had complete strangers who were there
who vouched for what happened but
I remember just being so angry about the
mud that I got dragged through it's hard
to let go of that kind of anger when you
didn't do something and somebody says
you did it's a tough thing in my stomach
so this is one of those things I think
if nothing else it proves his bias
against women accusers right I don't
know what happened
he says it didn't happen so fine
whatever but man that's understandable
what he's saying if that happened the
way that he described he's falsely
accused of something but then was
cleared that would be upsetting sure
right but what he says here is
interesting is it's hard to let that go
right
which is fair but it all a little bit it
proves a bias it might have a little bit
of a bias going in yeah so this is this
is a good atmospheric in my opinion
because it at a sense I go why are they
so anti
women accusers like every time
and I guess it's an interesting insight
into the psychology of it so here is um
how they describe that phone call first
of all and I'm gonna try to work through
this fast they say H3 goes after fresh
and fit with fake me too claim again
straw and man uh we never said it was a
metoo she literally called in to share a
bad date so the way they're framing this
is is already
super [__] dishonest fake me too shut
the [__] up losers
now it's not because she did act like
that and that story didn't go unfor it
probably unfolded the way she says and
unfold but my girl
this is on you but it's on you
girlfriend so so Babel or Babylon Creeks
says
that I believe what she said but it's
still your fault did you catch that let
me go back it act like that and that
story didn't go up the girls that age
because of when I was working with in
God damn it does this make sense to
anybody listening and what about the
friend does the friend just looking
they're like with a gun to her head I
believe what what she said he believes
her happened
how Progressive of him nice okay let's
wrap it up let's say goodbye no because
of when I was working with in Social
Services and stuff like that blah blah
blah
they act like that who's they the girls
that age
they act like that they really do now
it's not because she did act like that
and that story didn't go unfor it
probably unfolded the way she says it
unfold but my girl
this is on you but it's on you
girlfriend just to be clear when you say
it happened like that you're not saying
that it was this weird creepy thing
you're just saying that the girl died
she thought it was creepy and still went
with it that's what I think I don't know
so this is awesome this is fantastic so
he goes I believe her
but it's still her fault and then Abba
goes I don't believe her and it's still
her fault I think this is a whole
[__] lie it's a work
this is how dumb this whole thing is it
literally can't be possible for someone
to say this goofy [__] and it happened
the way that they claim you don't text
the guy that's a really nice nuanced
take on this situation you know preach
ends up changing his opinion
he goes yeah you're right she's lying
yeah but I love that he said that he
believes her but it's still her fault uh
we'll get into the details of that of
course uh
they say it's her fault she was there
she has privilege it's just low budget
I'm not Shyamalan he's been telling you
you claim okay I'm not saying your side
you claim he's pushing he constantly
tells you he says I want to bring you
back to my place so you can see what I
can handle it's 5 a.m he picked you up
from the club took you back home
separated you from the girl every
indication said that y'all was [__]
tonight and yet imagine a world where
she's still not obligated to [__] him
crazy huh
and then you guys want to say he
couldn't read the room why the [__] are
you there
oh but you can't ask that because that's
victim get the [__] out of here bro get
the [__] out of here man that is the
most privileged position in the world
where you can walk through life and
think you can make the most crazy crazy
decisions after being told this is
what's gonna happen you maybe don't date
a 19 year old girl oh my God what I
didn't catch that the first time I
watched this yeah it's wild this is the
peak privilege is uh
having the expectation that uh you can
say no to sex okay that's a privilege
that's that's the height of privilege
guess what guess what happens when
you're 35 year olds and you're famous
people might want to [__] uh hang out
and see what your studio is like and all
these kinds of [__] uh privileged girl
you should have just [__] him let's be
real you owed him
yeah
it's awesome it really didn't hit me
they're awesome no they really are they
got her good and wait till she's what
wait till they she sees wait till we see
what they say she's lying about you come
back to my place we gonna make out we're
gonna [__] you just know all this you
sure I'll be like whoa
hey try to [__] me I know he told me for
the last hundred times he was gonna try
but he
was very nice
pretty good on that one eh
then we're moving on
here they have a moment where they
she says something really important and
instead of actually responding they just
laugh they just laugh that's their whole
response check this out yeah
right right it's okay let's not relive
that moment so I just pushed him off and
I was like oh I'm just gonna go to the
balcony and he goes you need mouthwash
yeah what yeah I was texting my friend
the whole time and you see me say like
he just told me to get mouthwashed or
something yeah let me pull up this text
again guys we have receipts this is
fully vetted bro mine just grabbed me
to make out and he goes get your
Listerine you taste like alcohol
no he obviously knows you came from the
club he's disgusting so I come back in
the room and then I go to the bathroom
like in the kitchen he's like that's not
where the mouthwash is so I was like oh
okay um where's the mouthwash
laughs
something yeah he got shot again
wasn't it holy [__] that fit in So
Perfect oh that was him
apparently something really funny
happened
but this is their whole response to that
part
they're saying because she asked where
the mouthwash is that that she was into
it that's my interpretation that's why
they're finding this funny I mean again
oh this is one of their this is one of
their evidence that she's lying is
because a 19 year old girl who you said
is immature you guys are like yo what's
with 19 year old girls who's been taken
to a 35 year old guy's house
and he goes yo you need to take
mouthwash I mean
yeah she might do the mouthwash even
though she doesn't tend to [__] him you
know what I mean
I could see that yeah it's not that
funny actually it's not funny
they do think so we need the big things
we need to fix things they don't even
verbalize the floor man wait yeah it was
looking down the floor maybe maybe
getting the truth oh man you've got the
drill you've got the drill right there
tighten up those screws oh well can I
get an insight into a reaches uh thought
process on that one
right
yeah he's thinking hard
he's thinking hard but nothing happens
so that's their whole response and you
this is that's it that's that's all they
said about self-evident that's it we
need to fix this
excellent uh Abba's conclusion here is a
this and now let me remind you this is
their reaction before fresher food ever
put out quote receipts or anything this
is just their snap judgment is it just
straight up be like she's a lying
how do you watch any of this
as somebody that doesn't like fresh and
fit and have made fun of them and
criticized them in the past and not see
this as a story that's showing
confirming your suspicion that Myron is
a [__] loser like though he has no
game he couldn't
he this girl didn't want to sleep with
him he's doing all these dudes there was
a lot to take from this other than oh
this [__] [__] is a liar you know
what I mean like she said she found a
stash of Plan B in the bathroom
dude
but you all know because they're again
and again they call it a me too thing
it's just like it what all that happened
right is that you at one point said that
sounds like that might be assault and
she said no I don't see it though I'm
gonna show that coming up when we watch
the second video what the [__]
um
yeah it's straw and man you know what I
mean you know there's like nobody says
[__] crazy and their whole thing is
like that I'm trying to persuade her
consistently to say it's essay there was
one brief moment where she said he
lifted up her top and I was like yo that
sounds [__] up
you came to his place at 5am okay made
the most mixed signals I've ever seen
and by all indications looked like you
guys were gonna [__] then you said no
ask me these guys they're like 33 and
forget that let me see the other one
yeah them in their 30s dissecting the
social like implications of the way a 19
year old girl is like showing her
interest is so embarrassing yeah 33 and
39 so embarrassing and they they again
he's such a coward right he spells it me
too I'm assuming intentionally wrong
because he's like being a little baby
he's like I'm not gonna actually say me
too in case YouTube thinks it's naughty
at their big age you would think that
they know that someone wants to have sex
with them if someone tells them that
they want to have sex with them they
don't know them no they don't and it's
embarrassing they are straight up
default position women are lying yeah
and despite their mortal enemies fresh
and fit they're ready to ride
based on nothing you know really just
Based On A Feeling
and apparently they you're they have
this uh fetish for
[__] on me too because they defended
Crowder so this is like right up there I
guess they hate me more than freshness I
mean [__] oh no yeah okay you want to
leave okay give me a ride no why does he
owe you that you could say he's an
[__] you can say that's a douchey
thing we agree why is this a YouTube
video an action gives a [__] if the Mane
is douchey why is this a YouTube video
the reason why you're airing this out
that's the again like I said who cares
if a man is douchey I mean and man
that's the whole thrust of all the
[__] videos
weren't you the guy who's like it's not
that serious we're just beefing what the
[__] is your point there's no
consistency to anything you say you guys
are phony as [__] if you Pander to your
audience you have no convictions right
you know that's all you are and you lie
all the time too which I've proven by
the way either intentionally or not just
from straight up [__] negligence and
ignorance
in Predator that's why you're doing this
so let's be honest the reason why this
is Being Framed this way okay this is a
regular encounter where the dude's mad
they're not getting late and he says
leaf who cares
he was just a dick yeah that's why we
that's why yeah that was the why she
called he's somebody probably on the
internet that we beef with so and we
thought it was funny that he had a horde
of Plan B in his [__] drawer yeah but
I mean come on that's awesome they
really want to try and say that that's
not well they didn't bring that able to
learn about they didn't buy that up
of course they'd improve yeah the drawer
of Plan B that means he's planning on
nutting in multiple women with no
protection that's pretty wild in the
near future right because that [__]
probably goes bad after a minute imagine
a single dude imagine Myron he goes to a
pharmacy yo can I get five Plan B please
I mean that's funny okay I'm sorry y'all
don't think so but apparently jokes are
jokes or global warming is uh real I
don't know something about global
warming
you guys see how phony you are
I hope I'm getting through you I'm not
nah
I know exactly what they're going to do
in response and I don't care they're not
it's not going to get through them
they're going to try to
take they'll take everything a straw man
it and like everything they've already
been doing they were laughing walking
off screen
at least I mean there is
at least in the past I don't know but
somewhat of an overlap in our audiences
and in the times in the past that you've
mentioned
these guys being annoying to you or
whatever I do see some feedbacks like no
no don't fight uh I like both both you
guys or whatever so maybe we're at least
clarifying some other people in our
audience why yeah yeah we're not fans
like I would come across their videos
doing research I like their videos a lot
I didn't when the first time I ever saw
them was a video of them
viciously roasting fresh and fit right
which is what makes this also ironic and
he's like the statement why is this a
YouTube video oh he's a douche who cares
I mean you've made that video right
that turned me off from them is the
Crowder video when I first saw that I
was in shock I'm like what is going on
right because it's just so reaching yeah
it's like come on
one of the hardest things to force
someone to do yeah yeah
yeah and then play the cube star one
close your mouth
right good points all around he acted
like it who cares and the funny thing is
that he actually when you actually
verbalize the note
but you have no stories yeah and she
never claimed that he did that she never
[__] claimed it you jokes you frauds
your default position is [__] women
don't you see that all right moving on
to the second video so um now that fresh
and put fresh and fit did a podcast
where they showed all the receipts
proving she's a liar and then they did a
second video called uh we were right
she's lying or some [__] like that so um
here's an example of
what they use to prove she's lying they
keep saying it she's a liar people need
to know who she is here's her name
here's her face they show text messages
that implied that he didn't try to
separate them she claimed that
the club was only one mile away and she
said she was stranded
she was wearing fresh and fit merch and
she was suggesting ideas for sound drops
for the show
that she was already drinking when she
arrived there
and that is basically proof that she's a
liar and needs to be doxxed and harassed
interestingly though
Myron and his video trying to defend
himself confirms the worst part of her
story okay
you guys are gonna love this it's a six
hour podcast by the way holy [__] yep
Jesus
that's crazy yeah
I mean we're at three so we're halfway
there I mean that's still a far cry man
three is a big difference from sick
we'll see how early week I think we're
actually almost done
uh context so here here's what they're
saying here let's take a look
and so I'm like I have my hands like on
him where it's like I don't want him
like laying on me like intimately so I'm
just holding my hands up and I'm like no
no no this was about like
Max a minute long and I was wearing like
this shirt and it's like a very loose
shirt whatever and he basically lifts up
the shirt and made a comment and then I
was like I'm done I'm over this like I
lifted up your shirt and kind of looked
at underneath it and commented yeah yeah
my chest because I have I have piercings
I'm sorry you say what
I said I have piercing so he made a
comment on it oh okay
and it was very creepy Myron's laughing
right now because he remembers so I I I
I don't wanna
no it was not creepy she's mad because I
basically made a joke about her titties
being lopsided whatever so
what he's effectively done is admit that
he did lift up her shirt and look at her
titties now if somebody does that
without your consent what is that
that's cool
you can't see why I was visibly bothered
by that uh fact which I didn't know
going in
y'all don't think that that's a little
bit strange oh but they're there well
she and she she pushed back on she said
I didn't feel like it was assault and he
said okay fair enough but and they use
that again I feel like it's
understandable for you to hear that
detail and you're having a conversation
to to ask that you didn't say That's
assault you said that kind of sounds
like assault I mean I don't know it does
kind of sound like that yeah and then
she said no I don't think it was and
then okay and then Myron goes yeah it
happened and I made fun of her lopsided
titties too
Jesus insane
okay and so their whole thrust is
Ethan's a giant piece of [__] he was
trying to get her to say its essay the
whole time total lie total [__] lie
all right there you go and by the way
this is in ab and preach's video so they
saw this okay
and they go oh that's [__] up you
shouldn't talk about her body it's like
um
please say that yeah okay no but they're
missing the [__] point they spent the
whole time calling her a liar and then
when the when he admits to doing the
worst thing they don't see it for what
it is they spent two videos calling me
and her Liars that we worked
intentionally orchestrating a fake me
too
it's it's insane it's insanely
disingenuous
um
here they say Ethan implied repeatedly
it's essay let's check it out in this
narrative even though she said oh I
don't think he did a crime whatever
listen the way you've said this story
the way that you guys are framed it the
fact that Ethan keeps implying it the
fact that most of the people the comment
it was one time it was literally one
time I said that's what he did we all
understand what you're framing okay you
can't say I didn't say you did that
crime but you're like oh yeah yeah uh
well you know he did grab a knife and
then put inside me oh so he stabbed him
no no I'm not saying he stabbed me I'm
just saying like you know I was
uncomfortable what
yeah what okay I agree but uh she said
he lifted my top yeah what was the
analogy that he made he's giving a
completely it doesn't fit with would you
say given circumstances at all would you
say extreme because he's criticized
Ethan for extreme examples extreme
analogies oh right I would never do that
hahaha
I would never compare everything to
Adolf Hitler at every opportunity
Isis I mean those are powerful analogies
they were good so what's being said that
doesn't mean that this dude's not a
loser okay that doesn't mean that this
dude is not a goober okay but it does
when she lifted up he lifted up her
shirt and she was very uncomfortable
their take is she was there at 5am uh
she should have [__] him
so if he lifted up her her shirt and
made fun of her lopsided titties then
that's on her making fun of her tits is
not the problem like yeah that sucks and
that's horrible and you shouldn't have
done that and he's an [__] he
shouldn't have lifted up her shirt
that's [__] crazy I didn't dispute
that you notice right no he did it and
they didn't they didn't have anything to
say about it he was laughing and smiling
saying that should happen right and I'm
proud of it right and how old is it
again 35 and she was 19. all of these
men making these horrible arguments are
so old and so embarrassing as a side
note to add on to what Jan was saying
about their response video fresh and fit
you really see what [__] losers they
are like I don't know how any of these
incels believe them he had an exchange
with this girl this 19 year old for
about I think it was like a month going
back and forth trying to hook up with
her for one 19 year old girl he was he
was like like he's trying so hard yeah
maybe that plan B isn't getting any use
right and I think the plan I think the
plan B is an in-cell Flex I think he
just has it oh yeah give these [__]
Plan B the only time I've ever seen a
bowl of Plan B is that school in the
Health Center on the weekends they would
leave it on the counter I don't
understand what's for you he's like yeah
I practice unsafe sex
what about it
um
so like you can see how in their
desperate attempt to not believe any
women right their default position is
women be lying
um
they're wrapping themselves into a
pretzel right I can see it Their
audience can't because they don't show
them everything they're [__] Liars
yeah and they hate and I I think I
generally think that they just
women be lying
and shopping
people who gets snakes
man who does that losers yeah so he's
upset about it but apparently I wasn't
worth talking about why did it happen
why did it happen why did we make that
video yeah he's he's that's right
there's no consistency he had no
interest of courting her was hey all
two you don't have to do that okay
my point being uh I think reach uh was
gonna make a point what was he thinking
about
[Music]
right right
I can I can understand his thought
process
very good
so uh there they go they keep and now
every time they bring up this story it
gets worse and worse check this out they
bring it up in a later video and now
they characterize it like this
learn to leave you want to know why we
didn't because Ethan what you did was so
goddamn [__] stupid you brought on
some young teenager to come tell
salacious lies about another man just
because you dislike them so much you're
willing to allow someone come on tell
disparaging lies just to get back at
them you lack so much character that you
bring on a [__] liar try to encourage
her to say that she was somehow like bad
this is very bad right I just these are
the dudes who don't care about internet
beef by the way it's cringy to them
also they're lying about someone lying
right now because they don't like you
right true quick pop off hey you know
what feminist loser pipe down right
you're right I'm too loud hit the button
use our feminist researcher who spends
all her Day on Reddit boards and thinks
that's research okay I've assaulted you
I mean at this point I yeah I mean I
don't want to say that but like again
like
that was the entirety that's it that was
it I'm gonna let you make your
assumption right just because you hate
somebody that's how twisted you are in
your head and you got the audience it's
really not that big of a stretch let's
be [__] real
like what again that clip that they
showed based off of what she described I
don't think it's that big of a stretch
for you to ask that question and again
she pushed it back
I'd like to ask that you're making such
a [__] big deal out of it I don't get
it they made it sound like I came here
with the intent to persuade her to
accuse them of some crime right now I
ask you guys what do you call it if
somebody lifts up somebody's top to
expose their breasts without their
permission
is that just a joke
or is she just he's entitled to do
whatever he wants to her because it's 5
a.m and she's why is she there like
genuinely if it's that crazy of a
statement you tell me what you think
someone lifting their top is against
their consent he admitted to that by the
way so don't even sit try to [__] say
she's lying because he just laughed and
smiled and said yeah that [__]
happened so go ahead and tell me please
I'm dying to know there's no it's not
that one Defenders you're just so
[__] unethical
and then I go to the bathroom like in
the kitchen yeah you didn't have to do
women be lying you made a choice
women be lying you made one before they
put out the receipts okay and after one
based on feelings and then one based on
some really [__] stupid [__] and
including them admitting to the worst
part and he's like that's not where the
mouthwash is so I was like oh okay
um where's the mouthwash oh yeah so we
saw this so there they are uh building
the mythology of
this girl lying and me uh somehow trying
to get her to do fake me too stuff it's
crazy it's actually crazy but here this
gets really interesting okay again this
is in the same vein as like the bottom
of controversy they think that
I don't know what they're trying to do
but this is good okay and Ethan you
might wish that somebody did the same
for you because I remember very recently
you were in some kind of little Scandal
where people were claiming that you guys
were demonstrating your employees and
left a bunch of reviews and you said
these are all false these are all false
well guess what guess what
why don't we believe the people who
claim that you did something wrong you
wanna know why because we require
evidence proof that people are telling
the truth about him admitting it
happened about him saying yeah okay I
love that he thinks that leaving an
online review is equal to
an assault allegation which she didn't
do by the way right but I just want to
say it didn't really happen again like
there wasn't really an allegation oh
there was a question yeah it's all
YouTube drama it's all creative but even
basically he's saying videos based on
his logic even it doesn't make no
[__] sense
yeah
oh my God I'm not I'm I'm not a joke
again it's like they're just trying to
bring up their to be like look at this
[__] guy but leaving a review on a
website
that anyone can leave a review on is the
same in their minds as a woman making an
accusation and again they continue to
group them all up all accusations are
created equal so that they can just the
L women be lying I mean this is my day
it's the same as leaving a fake glass
door review somebody did the same for
you because I remember very recently you
were in some kind of little Scandal
where people were claiming that you guys
were demonstrating your employees and
left a bunch of reviews and you said
these are all false these are all false
well guess what guess what
why don't we believe the people who
claim that you did something wrong
go ahead do whatever you want bro do
whatever you want I said what I said and
I mean I it's not like I was like well
to be fair this person's 100 telling the
truth right which is what it did right
yeah this person said that uh we made
them work in cages well we do do that
but it's funny but the rest of this is
[__] yeah it's all [__] you
[__] clowns You Are
a clown I hope they never have daughters
well fate Fate has a cruel way of uh
making sure that dudes who shouldn't
have daughters have daughters and you
know too she shouldn't have sons have
sons I found that to be true it's
interesting
um
so okay now here's the they've they have
gone out and said this girl is lying
right Stephen she's a liar fake me too
claim proof she's lying where's the
evidence
we brushed over this left this is a hit
piece and that's exactly what the [__]
that there's girls that act exactly like
that I said that that's what I mean that
age we'll go and do that for ego
because they need to prove some [__]
[__] that was a hundred percent ego
right just to prove something oh you
think you know you think you're good I'm
perfect that's a hit me though
until you put your her face and name out
right and said go harass her
this
kind of behavior
does not show
whenever they say that you know what
it's only ten percent of uh claims that
are false claim this is a false claim
but it's not reported so now they're
using this to make the larger argument
that
it's reported that there's only between
like five and ten percent false claims
so they're saying no it's actually way
way way higher because this girl lied
about uh
my room about uh
uh her drinking before she went there or
something uh claims that her false claim
this is a false claim it's not
it's not a claim but it's not reported
because
fresh or fit or not going to report that
[__] it's not a claim that's why I
wasn't reported things like that happen
because they feel ashamed because
because this
women
create false allegations in Mass
way more than you would expect because
they're embarrassed because they're
ashamed for ego yeah you cannot put it
in any in any clearer
in any clear sense it really is yeah
that's that's a fresh and fit take it's
like they are exactly it's like really
not that far off
I can't hear you
should use Olivia's like
excuse me
yeah excuse me loser uh fresh their
video is when hashtag believe all women
goes wrong I'll just add on to that oh
there and in the description it says
save a man's life uh with uh this video
save a man's life Myron was gonna be his
life was destroyed by uh girl saying
he's a bad date yeah
how old they are and how young she is
yeah but they they are fresh and fit
that's what's interesting and this is
just misogynistic just [__] trash
just trash they go
they go the studies say five to ten
percent I don't believe it though
because of this story it's obviously way
way higher than that
you have to believe all the science if
you do you believe in global climate
change people live in global warming
if so you have to believe I irreputed
bro I'm sorry
they need to prove a point because they
dislike someone some they also have a
take about oh believe all women is
[__]
uh I don't know if I time stamped it but
I remember seeing that one will do that
we'll do
women will do that
women be trying to ruin men's lives it's
quite it's just what they do I'm gonna
go out of my way to lie I don't like him
so I'm just gonna go lie about him
assaulting me that is such an insanely
hurtful thing to say about any woman
ever it's a very humiliating experience
to go through something like that and
for for anyone to assume that like
someone claiming being a victim or
surviving something is them like wanting
to boost their ego is so incredibly
wrong and informed and uninformed that
like you one million percent should not
be making content about this because
you're teaching young men who don't know
anything about this and then you're
telling young women to not talk to each
other to not talk to anyone to not tell
anyone that something happened because
idiots like you old ass idiots like you
will say no no young girls act like that
young girls act like that when really
what's happening is that a young girl is
dealing yeah a 19 year old was tried to
get picked up by a 35 year old and you
know what you sound like a feminist
loser though if you're just going to
interject I do I do I'll say it again
she's the loser feminist researcher who
spends all her down Reddit boards and
thinks that's research okay guys I'll
take it back yep reel it back in yep
there
this is who they are this is this is
what I'm trying to say they're not
better they are fresh and fit
just with a nicer veneer
yeah like to create a a degree of
Charisma yes exactly yeah I'm fresh and
fitter
they're not like uh him but the
underlying beliefs are
indistinguishable so
she told us she was crying when she left
it was a difficult she felt humiliated
so
they're more they're more concerned with
35 year old Myron's
yeah being exposed is being kind of
cringe
because again that's that's pretty much
the extent of this it's so pathetic you
guys are so unserious so pathetic it's
awesome the whole story didn't do that
but it's not going to be responded
reported why because guys shut the [__]
up about that [__]
men men don't be lying women they do be
lying
men men are cool
they don't talk [__] women they lie
you know
whatever you come and talk to me about
false claims that are reported it's only
that shut the [__] up about that [__]
because that [__] is not real yeah yeah
yeah yeah that is not real preach
literally
back up the science on that one please
hey Zach can I hear the science on that
one [__] dumbass dude
that's convincing
yeah
I just want to appreciate something we
glad story this last time but just think
of how manipulative and how much of a
[__] loser you have to be to despise
someone go out of your way to interact
with this person so you can then
afterwards reject them so you want to
lead somebody on talking about a 19 year
old girl
who this 35 year old [__] loser whose
whole Persona is that he's the Slick
Alpha women Destroyer
he spent a month trying to [__] this
girl
couldn't and then he got rejected and
somehow it's on her
now now uh uh uh
what's uh
uh bab or reaches uh the squeaky guy
squeaky head
um preach squeaky brain right he was
just going on and on about how he
believed her because 19 year olds are
lame
okay dude pretend you have intro so you
can be like you [__] loser you wanted
me get out of here I would never how
much of a loser you have to be to go out
of your way to spend time with people
you apparently dislike yeah okay yeah
good question you should really wonder
about the adult
uh who who's participating uh so let's
see
um that I thought was pretty good now
when we're talking about the lies that
she's told again
they're taking this for granted she is a
[__] liar they say it in the title
say repeated in the videos despite Myron
admitting to the worst part here is my
favorite slam dunk on so this is the
second part this is why that made me
laugh so remember she's like oh I don't
know how to get home
stranded I'm gonna show y'all how
and entitled these girls are and how
close they coconuts I see is really
he's engaged he's he's right there with
you brother he's trying to keep up he's
winning his best he's doing his best we
need a coconuts and squeak podcast
they just silently stare at each other
they just nod a lot
that whole podcast is you and Gabe uh
having a stare off right it is that's
that
more that might be more insightful uh
comments from that one than the regular
you want to do it Dan yeah here's a
preview of uh coconuts and squeak
[Music]
you got me ah nice you got me they
actually were they could have uh went
ahead and gotten it themselves uh Bureau
of Prisons uh uh doubt Miami you guys
want to see how [__] lazy these
tricks are one mile
girl my girl my girl my girl one mile
whoa wow
everybody got that on their phone women
be lying to the GPS
I'm stranded
you again let me be lying dudes to get
your keys back they're one mile away do
you know how entitled and [__] lazy
you have to be to forget some [__] after
you get a ride from somebody and to
demand that they come deliver to you
they're one mile away
but anyways let's keep playing okay slam
dunk let's let's be let's be honest
about this
it's 5 A.M
that one mile walk is 26 minutes
we pulled up the route that he showed
here's what he showed on his show
this route takes you through downtown
Metropolis Miami
5 a.m 26 minutes probably wearing heels
because she was out clubbing
now is this now is this a a walk that
you would recommend somebody
or at least yeah get off your entitled
ass and walk through
at least at least don't act like it's
crazy that you know would you want your
sister or mom to take this walk would
you call her entitled hell no at least
don't act like it's crazy though and
then they go to work and then you know
she could have bought an Uber or I guess
she did ultimately get her own Uber but
again let's be real 5 a.m grow by
yourself and dress to go clubbing and
all that I mean it's still a little
sketch that's still a little bit
sketchable on Uber at 5am downtown Miami
I'm sorry it is so y'all really once
again showing the privilege that you
have saying No this [__] needs to walk
or call an Uber it's 5 a.m walk through
downtown Miami it's only one mile it's
1.4 miles but whatever through downtown
Miami at 5am
because she didn't [__] him yeah you got
some uh fans in the chat who live in
Miami that are confirming our subs are
suspicious definitely all right maybe
yeah I used to live in Florida yeah well
no I ain't walking down anywhere in
Miami At 5am by myself my ass is gonna
get groped walking down you are you are
cute thank you
[Laughter]
I don't think that's why people get
groped though yeah but you are cute it
might help
in your case yeah
yeah so again this is their big slam
dunk this is the type of evidence that
they're presenting as proof that she's a
liar right this is what they're showing
isn't that great yeah it's awesome
um
here's he he goes on people lie women be
lying
this is incredibly bad no and uh I think
content creators have to be more
responsible when they're platforming
these people not to just do this whole
[__] [__] of like believe women
that's what I do believe women
Chad's pointing out that also she was
drinking that night too yeah yeah drunk
girl he didn't put out letter walk let
her walk oh she's letter walk
at least don't act like it's crazy that
she asked for a ride you know what I
mean
don't [__] pretend that you would
want your mom or sister or any female
woman in your life to do that are you
Liars you cowards privileged they'd be
like I would do it
okay
very very uh empathetic
people lie they're Liars men lie women
lives everybody [__] lies
women be lying and you can't really
believe people
because when it's going to be your time
why does it lie and you left that's some
[__] you're gonna wish some people
actually had some scrutiny for the
people who are accusing you you made me
defend this dude
[Laughter]
they really thought again
he really thought he was doing something
they they set this up
you know uh or Babel or whatever the
[__] he had to exit frame
for squeaky brain for the people who are
accusing you you made me defend this
dude
I did not man you did that I know you
did that yourself I'm sorry bro but you
want you did that you made that you were
given all of the information and you
made that choice yourself you did that
brother I'm sorry man I wouldn't want to
defend them either it's embarrassing
yeah and frankly uh it does look bad
very bad it's actually really gross it
looks very bad that they're uh defending
him just because they don't like you
hmm interesting Theory I think I've
heard that argument although they also
don't like women right yes women excuses
even and even in women yeah so two is
more than one
no
at the end of the day what we defended
was the principle it's like if you lied
you locked yeah you like I don't care if
it lies against somebody I don't like
again they're proof she should have
walked
it's awesome so uh there that is sorry
that I made you do that I know it is
very embarrassing
um and then now now let's remember
through all the crazy [__] they said
about her and I didn't even show I
showed a scratch of it they have been
dogging her and saying the worst things
imaginable now after all that in this
thumbnail her face is blown the [__] up
half the thumbnail it's just a straight
up shot of her face and then squeaky
brain uh reach says this thing you could
have just said wait what does he say
no not that he actually verbalized this
that you could have just said that and
even if he said that
he said that he made a comment about
your boobies
was it worth all the LIE
all of that now you just look stupid
Danielle
yeah I'm saying your name because
[__] have to know your name the
same way you try to frame a [__]
like that people need to know who the
[__] you are yeah just so they know that
you're a piece of [__] you want to frame
them as a piece of [__] but the bigger
the biggest piece of [__] in this story
is you it's you I mean do you even need
to say anything honestly
and again I have to emphasize
Byron admit to the worst part of the
story on video that you guys watched and
here you are saying here's her name
here's what she looks like people need
to know who you are explicitly saying
that with malice people need to know he
said go [__] with this girl
now I'm the doctor who needs to be
banned on YouTube you guys are [__]
monsters for this do you I don't think
they understand how insane how [__] up
this is
it's a vile
here they go and you know how we keep
saying like um she was 19 he's 35. they
don't think that's a valid excuse see
because people keep mentioned the age
listen I think young women are annoying
as [__] I never want to be around them
if they come around me I'm always
disgusted do you think I disgusted he's
he's trying to convince us he doesn't
like young girls just a little too hard
it's like
I don't like our annoying they're
annoying it's fine I don't want to be
around them I don't want to be around
like he's like angry it's like
disgusting my God all young women you
hate they disgusted he's like whoa what
the [__] is that whoa whoa whoa hold on
there's something going on here yeah
look at the rage look at his face yeah
no there's something going on here it's
really important this whole thing
because people keep mentioning the age
listen I think young women are annoying
as [__] I never want to be around them
if they come around me I'm always
disgusted I don't like being around them
okay there's nothing appealing yeah but
I also he's like yeah my little sister
my little cousin I [__] [__] hate
him disgusting cool I'd never watched I
love dudes dudes of all ages are dope
love them all yeah what's your argument
interesting take by Prager except that
there are adults they may not be the
most mature adults but they are adults
and if they want to go and [__] whoever
they want that's it and if you got a
problem with that that's cool or not
[__] whoever they want that's a problem
we're not acknowledging that as well and
say they're not mature enough they're
prefrontal cortex doesn't develop to the
25. fine but then change and you have to
keep the same energy
for changing the age of consent to 25 in
all categories they can't vote till
they're 25 they can't do only fans until
25 they can take student loans for 25.
they're really not an
adults without their parents being sent
to a 25. that's the standard we have to
sit if you want to say they're two
or not you have to keep it consistent
across the board until you do that I
don't want to hear nothing about that
that's fine so that that's how we go
ahead no we're good all right let's not
got it nailed it so his theory is if you
think the fact that a 35 year old man
is trying to [__] a 19 year old and then
complaining that she's immature
that if you want to bring up the age
difference then you gotta
uh raise the age to vote to 25 age of
consent to 25 drink alcohol 25 that's
brilliant that's [__] brilliant
they're just trying desperately to have
a say in this conversation that they
don't
like drama I'm 23. so please hold up
please yeah I'm gonna need your drive
I'm gonna need your driver's license
researcher who spends all their deal on
Reddit boards and things actually Olivia
welcome home please you know what okay
I deserve it
that's it we reached the end so in
conclusion
these guys who present themselves as
holier than thou better than are
honestly
as bad and in some cases worse because I
see them serving as a Gateway into this
really toxic manosphere uh transphobic
misogynistic women be lying type of
thing they are fresh and fit they think
they're better but they're not they're
just a little smarter and a little
squeakier
um
go ahead Zach
[Music]
now I doubt any of this will get through
to them they're gonna do anything they
can to avoid actually engaging honestly
and thoughtfully with anything we've
said
the one thing I would like to at least
see them
apologize and correct on is when they go
um
he went on that long ass [__]
monologue about
me missing the avoiding the Hassan video
he says I've missed the Hassan video
that was a lie so I need to apology for
that
and also about the whole homophobia rant
when I didn't say anything about gay and
you went on a whole five-minute
monologue about that I would like an
apology and correction for that one as
well
and I think you should apologize to the
girl you doxed and put her face and name
out there based on the fact that she
didn't want to walk uh based on the fact
let's see
they show text message saying that he
that they didn't try to separate them
the club was only one mile away she was
wearing fresh and fit merch and
suggested a sound drop for the show that
she had already been drinking when she
arrived that
um
you need to apologize that's your
evidence I have my hands like on him I
don't want him like laying that's by
watching them at least I'm just holding
my hands up and I'm like no no no this
was about like Max a minute long and I
was wearing like this shirt and it's
like a very loose shirt whatever and he
basically lifts up the shirt and made a
comment and then I was like I'm done I'm
over this like I lifted up your shirt
and kind of looked at underneath it and
commented yeah yeah my chest because I
have I have piercings
I'm sorry you say what
now I said I have piercing so he made a
comment on it oh he's loving it was very
creepy he's like yeah I did that [__] I
I don't want to
no it was not
as I basically made a joke about her
teeth whatever there you go that's your
boy good job I made you defend this man
I'm so sorry about that he said it
wasn't creepy no it wasn't creepy yeah
never mind and by the way just one thing
for the road next time somebody uh next
time you laugh in response to being
accused of transphobic just pull this
video up so uh we're gonna sign off
now the organizer told me was about a
video I did about trans people and
knowing our catalog we've only done two
videos about trans people a few moments
later the trans person the trains not
transport okay hold on just fade me out
yeah I want to just show it full screen
yeah okay so uh I've been banned from an
event now the organizer told me was
about a video I did about trans people
and knowing our catalog we've only done
two videos about trans people a few
moments later a trans person the trains
transports all transgender stuff the
trans women trans people trans you're
trained trans people you're strange
trans people trans women trans people
trans women trans women
trans we're not okay with terms of
transference trans men trans people
trans people who don't transplant trans
causes Transformers
trees
[Music]
transgender trans woman
Transformers
transmits trans
transforming trans women trans women or
women
ain't nobody trying to talk about y'all
that deeply you guys just won't shut the
[__] up and you guys are in every news
article always and trying to cancel
folks of course ain't nobody talking
about Native Americans or indigenous
folks the same way they're talking about
you no one's talking about the Maui
people the same way they're talking
about you the reason why folks talk
about y'all is because you guys put
yourselves out there all the time and
then constantly demand and change from
everybody
change
[Music]
then